all right and we are both live the last
word with a bot is in some friends
should we got a group we got a growth
campfire going on right now for us let's
go know what you about this man how you
doing man
I'll pretty good get my workout in this
morning and just trying to always find
time to get stuff in but I'm really
pumped for a second grow it launched oh
it was gonna be last night but if I can
get up were early get my workout in get
the podcast in get a video done but it's
like yeah I'm gonna be doing that whole
thing basically live on Twitch the whole
time which is kinda terrifying because
I'm gonna have many deaths as I learn
why it's not blood-borne and Dark Souls
I've watched you know do some edit
videos to know the changes that are
coming but yeah it's I'm gonna die alot
absolutely that I hate I'm really really
put like those games are like beyond
frustrating but also have like the
highest levels of like satisfaction so
yeah really I just hope there's nobody
like the nameless King otherwise I'm
gonna cry fair enough and we got
actually a Souls fan in here as well as
a desti fan my man from lords of gaming
that's what young became
mama Josh ready what's up Josh doing
well thanks for having me on the show
I'm excited to talk with destiny to
people more than just my wife I'm sure
she's like I'm good I'm good no a man
she she is put with those powers there's
bounties from The Drifter she is now a
higher light level than I am so then
she's putting in funding the work so we
do know it's glad to be here what class
I gotta know I'm obviously a warlock and
she's a hunter contrast small smarmy I
respect that and of course this man
needs no introduction one of the best
avatars that yet avatars law is amazing
this man has tremendous looter shooter
knowledge division King you don't say
one half I call you one half of tomax is
Emma my brother get a game before take a
chance a little ooh the shooter brothers
right there we're getting you on Forte
don't worry about but slow-mo man thanks
for coming on
by the campfire how you doing man hey
I'm doing great man this is a nice nice
Friday morning I'm still a little
exhausted from all my my division time
it's been a it's been a it's been a
great ride like the past week and a half
actually I think yeah I started I had
the early access so um ever since then
my hours of sleep has about a lot less
than what I'm used to I'm going to bed
at like 2:00 in the morning like may I
see I wasn't going to do this I did it
again but hey like you know it's it when
you when there's a game that comes out
and you in this your kind of game and
they really hit all the notes for you
everyone everyone goes to that period
where you just you know what sleek await
you having so much fun and I think what
you said is like it's almost like you
only just do one more thing and I can
get this done it turns into like two
three hours later right
right and also with me when I've been
doing this or like I've got I ain't
normally with the division of massive
and I'm saying when they give you
maximum of four different tunes to use
for different agents that you can make
I've already made all four agents yeah
I'm at gear score for 21 oh my I met for
my secondary I'm at level 12 and I'm
just at level 3 for the last two it I
basically made all of these so that like
I play on my main for the most part but
when I got like my my peoples who want
to get on and are like you know they
want some help they want something some
guidance I jump on some of the secondary
ones to kind of help them out with those
like R at the same level although some
of us some of the patch those that are
coming out I won't have to do too much
of that too much of that soon once like
what's that get on like later on this
evening they did a patch this morning
that I can talk about a little bit later
you know about some of the things that
they fixed and some of the bugs that uh
they had they seem to be getting ironed
out before they saw a drop in there
content but uh how are you guys liking
the game yeah I mean man I've been
playing a lot I mean for me it's been
you know it's been tough on me because I
know we're gonna get into destiny as
well cuz destiny I feel like isn't a
good narrative space right now you know
it's tough because I want to really
fully commit to division because I'm
having so much fun with it that's my
plan but then it's like I go back so I'm
just in this this tug of war this
push-pull you know not really getting
anything done on both sides but I've
just you know say in the mix got a deal
so I'll probably like I told you before
we know preached at probably like level
18 or so but really having fun you know
mission structure and stuff you know I
know II did you pick it up at all or
what's going on with you as far as ohm I
actually haven't got it yet so that was
like I believe me I'm going to it's just
been like I'm straight I was sakura's
come in it's like I know I'm gonna go
basically like main main line that one
so just and with destiny I was like I
was out of town for last week you know
it's really kind of killed those like
okay doing Tuesday work a couple days
and usually kind of start getting to my
gaming on like Thursday night Friday
morning I was gone from Thursday to
Sunday came back working Monday Tuesday
Wednesday so it's like I'm kind of like
I was like I will buy it but for me is
like I've just been kind of reading and
watching things from afar because I knew
I was gonna get Sakura I'll burn through
that and then I'll jump into division
when you know let them let them iron out
a few kinks but it sounds like it's
definitely got a boatload of stuff for
me to do it's like from what I've been
reading at least from what I've gathered
from you know slightly farther back to
you then you deep into it is you're not
gonna run out of stuff to do for a while
yeah like it's kind of crazy they
definitely will thought the game out
from in-game I'm starting from in game
on and like the in game is like the
foundation and then from there they've
created you know everything else and all
the additional content it's just it's so
much going on right now and these all we
always seem like I get on and I'm like
okay how am I going to tackle this today
I get into today you know it things that
like take yesterday for instance I left
work a little early
I was feeling under the weather
oh no that's so bad that you're feeling
sick and you know make sure the kids was
good they missing I know I'm on the game
and I'm doing stuff or in my worlds here
I'm at so shout out the method actually
to metha hit me a couple days ago he's
like hey slow-mo I can get you up to uh
you know your school for fifty real
quick and I'm like really sound like a
scam here are you serious he's like yeah
yeah I gotcha I gotcha okay alright so I
jump in with him yeah I just finished
the game and I got in game I'm in world
tier 1 and I was at like your score
level 230 yeah and he's like yeah and I
mean my boy we can get you up to 450
real quick you just joined us in our
worlds here hang back cuz you can't kill
nobody
and then and they will will drop some
loot for you see what happens so it
wasn't that easy they were dying left
and right and I had to help out a little
bit just a little bit but uh after
couple hours I was that like 4:15 okay
alright so um I'm thinking like I'm in
world tier 4 I feel kind of cheated I
feel like I kind of cheated the system I
mean really see well with my story yeah
yeah shot the style donut chat like he
actually told me the same thing like
there's kind of like a power level we
don't get it - we go yeah we gotta get
we go get it - it was gonna say his home
Josh how much have we played division so
I've put in about three to four hours
into the game and I didn't play the
division one so coming into I was kind
of interesting to see what the
onboarding process was like to pull and
kind of get me up to speed with all the
systems and mechanics and it's like
non-existent I have no idea even where
to find my gear score and I got new
kneepads and like those seem to be doing
cool things for me but the game
fundamentally is really fun to play um I
like the third-person shooter work on it
and I'm a big third-person fan like Dark
Souls like those kinds of third-person
action-adventure games are kind of where
I live not with the exception of destiny
and so playing the division feels kind
of like it feels comfortable and I like
the cover based shooter mechanics it
isn't quite as snappy as gears as it
doesn't have that kind of open way to it
but the shooting all feels really really
good in your hand the thing that I am
curious to see as I continue on in the
division is the reason why I like games
like destiny and for souls games and
Mass Effect is because of the world
that's built and kind of the mysteries
that exist within it so I'm curious to
see how deep into weird confirming
conspiracy theories and like national
treasure style like the division girls
like that's what I'm hoping to find in
the division beyond just solid gunplay
yeah man yeah you're in for a treat then
a lot of little stuff that that you'll
you'll just find just exploring like
sometimes you just get you you planned
on you set your waypoint marker for a
mission and you can't fast travel to it
so you go you know you take that path or
let me go block from block and see if I
can survive on my way there and then you
know you end up just in some village
you're looking at echoes from recordings
from things that happen before before
the the outbreak or sometimes they're
actually echoes out there explained to
you things that are happening on York
where the first game plays and and and
the aftermath of your actions there and
ship fly oh I mean over here and seeing
those like a hour has passed and I
haven't got to that Mickey yet pretty
much the same I mean I will say they
were much longer than that door which I
what I like a lot of them are just like
they're kind of like multifaceted
multi-part and I really like that aspect
and then I kind of like what you said
slow
another thing I'll notice is like going
from mission or objective to an
objective I'll get caught up just
messing around with the real real world
you know
action like you'll see you know some of
the settlement guys kind of making
Italian making patrols it just gives you
that illusion of like living world like
do people are doing stuff you know and I
like that I like that aspect a lot I
will say I'm not sold necessarily on the
narrative just yet one thing I wanted to
ask you guys about I'm sorry to jump in
quickly
be you know from that little farther
back perspective it's like a really I
think that the you know the gears crazy
depth you start with assets and I played
both demos I was like I got a pretty
good feel for it but I was like the one
thing that I've seen is like yeah it's
not really like there's not much of a
story I mean yeah you could be ID you're
taking over the cities but like really
it's you notice of the three people
talking in the darkroom or two and your
silent protagonist again which is that's
one thing I was like just anthem talk it
was nice but it's like how are you guys
feeling on the story do you care you
just like I mean the gameplays one is
like or is it just like the story is
kind of okay but I'm just enjoying the
gameplay kind of curious a guy's
thoughts on that one because it's one
I've read like in multiple different
places like gameplays awesome
customization specialization story may
that's like when I see a lot
I'll go first I'll give it to slow for
me I'm kind of in that pocket but mind
you I'm early right I'm not you know
slow with finish the game you know he's
on Earl T or whatever you know for me I
just get the sense like okay you know
I'm a badass getting there do do the job
like I'm not really getting any like I
got a couple of echoes I think I didn't
really get anything narrative way that
captivated me to know it was the mission
to Mission gameplay it was doing the
settlements it was those kind of things
in the gear in the loop and the in the
opportunity mechanics of that but I
gotta ask um you know slow now that you
as far as you are and you know obviously
you definitely the black tux must be
invading that host is going on and I
will say this like I did like seeing
like the bosses and the hunters and
stuff like that but from a narrative
standpoint like what what can you tell
us slow how are you feeling about
division 2 I do I do understand the that
the criticisms about the story it is you
anytime you have a silent protagonist is
very very difficult to really get to
invested in the story it's just kind of
reason wildlife over history like we
gone from sale
Chrono Trigger will chrono doesn't say
we're an Ori my favorite you to a best
friends right now we gonna talk we gonna
have some words just just saying like
you would have like a silent protagonist
a lot of times and and and back in those
days to now where you got like you got
your Master Chief's you have your
commander Sheppard's
you have your your voice for tagging
this you have your your Kratos and that
in any it allows the the developers to
be able to drive the narrative more in
form out of personality for for the
characters and that allow people to get
invested in that what you don't we have
a solid protagonist now it's almost kind
of a letdown I totally get that
I totally understand it I think this
game is is is very lore driven and that
narrative driven like if you want to get
understand allure and what's happening
and what happened to DC to get to get it
to the point where it is now there's a
there's a rich amount of information for
you to find to be able to get that and
so you can be people people see like
recordings from a guy like say and they
haven't played the first game but they
hear from a guy named this guy who's
this keener guy this is guy leaving like
really cryptic information and really
crazy so sociopathic messages to me is
like a lot of additional information
that you can find actually in the game
and that like outside the game they can
they be able to answer that information
for you but these far to go could
narrative I mean it's pretty much is the
city has gone to hell their gangs
everywhere you have a gun I guess I got
shoot people you know and but like yet
gameplay is is it's top-notch it's it's
they've really improved everything that
that they built the foundation for in
the first game and
and all the the issues that people have
with all the little two bullets bungee
or you know here and there they they've
gone and and just addressed everything
you got my race don't get you age yeah
that's what you know all that quality of
life stuff that we added as the the as
the updates went on from the first game
we're gonna have it all that there for
you day one in the second game and just
build upon it so I think that's why like
it's gotten a lot of really good reviews
and lack of feedback it's because P it's
just what people want it and they they
kind of kind of got what they wanted
and he gives to go back to what I was
saying about I said initially I felt
cheated kind of giving that power level
when I got the endgame when I got back
to my my world after leaving Methos
world they made sure that you still have
to grind out that work so like I'm still
in stunts I was at that time still stuck
in worlds here one I actually had to
complete the missions completely
strongholds do all that stuff you can't
just take the power level and say hey
I'm in world's here for now and work
like that don't work like that at all so
I I did some of that yesterday as I was
also helping other people get their uh
their characters up and show them how to
play the game a little bit some tips and
tricks like don't throw your turret on
the ground yeah someone's gonna come and
stomp on it you and be really upset
little things like that but then like
I'm an also kind of grinding myself up
now that world Tier three guy and I'm
not really like the built I haven't
really decided I have to builds in mind
I want to do with my main agent but I
haven't gone to the the point of
grinding those out yet because I as you
keep love getting your your gear score
up you'll keep replacing gear for right
now I'm just like it's not worth it for
me to go ahead and start climbing stuff
that I'm going to end up replacing
anyway so I'm just like one more i'ma
wait till I get the worlds here for him
put that work in so now respected me
John let me ask a question in reference
to just your experience as far as like
skill sets and I know you say kind of
early he's got a couple of knee pads
running around stuff like that but did
you get a chance to mess with
you and so I have the drone unlocks and
I like that quite a bit I think that the
cooldown timers are a little bit long in
terms of the special but ok good I'm not
the only one that kind of felt that way
I thought I was just being selfish give
me more drone warfare yes yes sauce
American position you can possibly take
but I like the most is I've kind of
spent about an hour just wandering
around the streets of DC I've been to
Washington DC a few times and it's
really neat to see the different parts
of the city I was in DC alas for of the
fourth of July actually three years ago
and it was cool to kind of walk around
and see basically like parts of the city
that I have walked around and had
pictures from and actually I kind of
want to do experiments where I walk
around and take the same pictures with
my character in the game at the same
locations but in terms of just like the
powers and abilities yeah I feel like
I'm too early to really give a kind of a
quantitative assessment of it beyond the
fact that I just think that the cooldown
timers are too long ok but I think that
they work really really well I think
about the game is so tight then I find I
have a hard time criticizing any
particular points um I feel like my beer
problems are gonna come more with like
the gear and like the overall ability to
make your character look unique in the
world which I think that that's kind of
I'm gonna struggle to find incentive to
grind out for high-level legendary loots
in terms of making my character look
awesome yeah I have a have a point about
that and it's sorry so I thought in the
end didn't want to interrupt you they
have like these loot boxes from supply
supply crates that didn't make quite
make it to the ground they're like stuck
in trees all over the world you can find
those you shoot them open and they drop
out died that allow you to just die your
gear whatever color that came out I have
like probably about Sarina I have a blue
one
like like a crimson color and a gold one
I've been just dying my gear time I put
on something new I'll make you up with
the die you make me so like I've been
walking around looking fresh everyone
knows looking at me with the mission I
think there's a couple of things here
and they're becoming you know give you
that that feeling of I want to look
unique and different and the first game
I will agree with Josh I don't feel
there's a lot of options though like as
a comparison option to a destiny answer
after they got some stuff like behind
store or you know say like I sort of can
go where that sort of police outfit I
certa
you don't say certain things but I don't
know I feel like it's there but I don't
know how to I don't get the feeling like
I'm incentivized to do a lot of it or
like as far as like I mean I'm gay I'll
get stuff here and there but it don't
feel like it's trying to push me towards
that loop box part yeah I will always
recommend people don't buy that stuff
don't buy it because like everything
that's in there that they can be
purchased can also be unlocked through a
loot crate or something and you get
little points towards you know just by
playing the game you get points towards
being able to put those points in get a
crate and then and get get some of those
uh those cosmetics on a lot yeah and
something that's really cool is this
they implement an algorithm to make sure
that you don't get the same loot twice
so every usual yeah it's not gonna be
any repeats of anything is always
something that you already didn't have
so which is very cool yeah uh wrap it up
on my side gets hold the impression
stays just that um look I'm really
enjoying it I love I love the difficulty
of the missions you know I'm saying well
in a shop Neil meant so what's going on
very happy Friday me oh yes one of our
agents in there um yeah I just love like
I said playing the missions the
difficulty aspect really impressed me to
a couple of issues that we had
work together you know nothing is
seamless I've been I have to admit
there's been some glitches with skills a
lot of times I've tried you know I turn
it out and you know it's in my hand but
it's not placing on you know the thing
wherever I want to place it but shop
they've been pretty responsive with the
patching I feel and updating the
community and I know styles in the chat
he's got an update right now on Lords of
gaming got net in reference to the
latest updates but they got to get the
skill stuff fixed you know there's a
couple little bugs here and there but
for the most part felt it was smooth I
think right now my favorite right now
skill is probably the hive where you
throw that little thing down and it
attacks a group of people like by killer
bees oh it's so much fun and then like
the the sniper turret is really cool
because it really helps me take down
like the yellow bars the armored guys
and um you have to mainly aim as well as
counter snipe and like I'll basically
hold the position with that I think the
healing skills are very underrated I was
playing with Brad slow and he he was
running on one of those I think healing
hive things and it's really helpful I
love the aggressiveness of the AI you
know whether they try to flank you rush
you you don't say they are trying to get
you out of that spot like grenade
launchers whatever they can is just I
just love it I love the fact that it's
tough it's not a walkthrough and at the
same time I have played solo and I have
done the aspect where you know if you're
about to take a control point you know
what you shoot that flare up and you get
them settlement help they're good
figured all by yourselves a bit dumb now
we're talking like my role this was
gonna ask how much have you guys
actually played solo how's that feel I
know when I played in the demos you said
the little help that you get from the
actual people you solid like it's
actually they're beneficial they're call
in for sure so I was just kind of
curious you guys thoughts on how much
time you spent solo and how it feels if
you're just like hey I don't have
anybody to play with how's that gonna be
an interaction
I actually think playing solo is way
more interesting than playing with a
group so I played I maybe split my time
between playing solo and playing which
is random is doing some I guess kind of
world events and I felt like when I was
playing with a group we
kind of could rush everyone and we were
spread out far enough in any given
mission that we could take out the enemy
without experiencing some of the more
advanced tactics that they use but when
I'm playing by myself yeah they're
flushing me out with grenades I can't
stay still I have to remain mobile the
entire time I had to be really judicious
about how I'm using my special abilities
and I really feel like I saw the AI come
alive when I was playing solo but when I
was playing with a group like I don't
know I felt like we were just an engine
of destruction and we weren't playing
some of the more advanced things though
we just kind of always had forward
momentum and then the enemy I didn't
really seem that suited to stopping us
what what may like weren't were too good
yes I like he's too good right I mean in
modest once again modesty is strong in
this part we humble member of Lords I've
played probably and in my for my main
character I probably did the max 30
levels I probably it's 25 of them solo
and I really enjoy tackling a lot of
those things soloing and because almost
like when you're when you're with a
group you kind of miss things you're
talking and discussing things with
people people are calling stuff out
later flanking on the left blah blah
blah blah blah you kind of missed little
things like when I'm healing and cover
the the enemies would be like he's
healing healing can get them and oh like
they'll press their attack when they
know I'm healing
well I thought well attorney yeah you're
in emanate when they I pull my drone or
something and the drone starts attacking
and they'll be like nothing's wrong
they'll get you know upset about certain
things that are going on you can see
them you can see them uh when he gets
down to just one guy left he starts
panicking at slipping and fall and
trying equation in the out of their hand
I love that that long continue it's
great man like I I've got I've always
enjoyed playing his games
like I played the first game solo for
the most part and I played with play
with a group as well but in the first
game you had 13 different gears gear
sets and I kind of expect them to
probably have that many gear sets
eventually with this game over time but
at least three afford them over the time
period of the first game were solo bills
they were designed for solo play like
nomads how do you say I want to stop you
right there for a second me because one
point of contention with my with the
cheetah myself very cold you go you know
I got to instigate Oh what what a
contention obviously you know ebon says
this is the economy he's the night falls
soloist this is the guy that plays solo
that will grind these games out by
himself and I know a lot of his
frustration and he likes the mode is but
it's the dark zone right and we know
about the dark zone this year you know
about the rotating you know I'm saying
occupied NOx or toxin or whatever but
you know his experience in there wasn't
necessarily the greatest so I'm gonna
give it to e he you tell slow what
you've been going through with that
aspect and I want to know if slow if
there's anything he can do maybe to help
alleviate that or it's just it is what
it is so eat tell them about your
experiences in the dark so it's like
it's been the same in d1 and d2 and it
was like my short time during that beta
was kind of the same way it's like so
take somebody like me didn't jump in
first day gonna be a little buying the
curveball and I don't know if the dark
zone on this one has like I know the
occupied is just like no holds bar
whatever you got you got and then the
others are supposed to be normalized but
take a solo person in the darks on hey I
wanna go in there see if I can find some
PvE guys and then just a lot group
before you walk through and be like tell
chip and you're just done and it's just
and I mean that's gonna happen I
understand that point but as that's like
one of the larger like hey this is kind
of your way to like mix it up go see
something different or go check out
these other dark zones they're not as
big this time it's not like people are
gonna be like hey it's like I've only
hang around like level one and level two
in the look like 4d1 it was the big long
giant dark zone bottom was like lower
tier stronger people might go you know
hang out in a group in the upper section
yeah if you go up there yeah you might
run into some people working it but the
patrols in there ones for me it's like
I understand there are solo builds in
there and I've seen people work some
people over just be like oh but no but
it's like as an average solo person
versus the trolls it was still one of
the most frustrating parts for me
because that was in d1 I know that was
where most the focus was and I kind of
stopped before you know they started the
tears and they started survival and
started other things I fell off a d1
after some of that but it's like that
initial and then like my first time in
the beta to go into the dark so I was
like oh cool I found one into me melted
by a three stack just walking around man
hunting people and they're on a full
five second I was like son of it it's
bet I know it's just like and that
feeling for me is like Cott its back and
it's just like mmm so that's my piece on
that one of like I know there's world
tears which I actually really loved it
added that later on a d1 they've got
this in d2 so you can just walk around
and most of that's PvE and I like how
there's a lot more options and then some
people if they want to go full pvp they
can go into the actual you know PvP
modes themselves specifically but as
dark zone is one of those things that
may not be as big of a focus now I don't
know but it's just one of those that
most the time it's that's one of the
things that burned me I was like hey I
kind of got some and drops and some of
the drops you get to keep and I'm
guessing still the good ones you have to
get out of there I guess with the
helicopter at yeah yeah I was looking
for so I was like I know the better ones
are still gonna take that extraction if
you got a manhunt team it's harder to
run from the manhunt team at least cuz
they're smaller and people are like oh I
can probably get there and two and a
half minutes however long it takes to
extract like it's gonna take some time
and they're like oh let's go mess with
them and you did not much a solo player
can do so kind of curious to guys
thoughts on all that okay
well I'll stay first they they
definitely address the your concerns
there are a lot of people from the first
game that felt that way they felt like
the dark zone was really unfair they
didn't fit they didn't like the fact
that in the first game you had to go
into the dark zone to get the best loot
and that was it they addressed that in
the first game around a be one point
four which came out maybe like nine
months after launch but a lot of people
Hale already checked out by that so
completely understandable that a lot of
people didn't know that but in this game
what they've done to address that is
with as you know the normalize dark zone
so there's there's three dark zones down
and in Division two ones occupied to an
alas the normalize is like everyone
stats are normalized but the talents in
perks some of the talents on your
weapons aren't the damage level is
normalized but the the talents of your
weapons and gear can still give you an
advantage so it's really about like your
build like how you build your your
character and before you go in and
determine a lot and that may seem it's
like as you say as an average player
that's a that that might feel like I'm
at a disadvantage from people who play
longer but I mean just based off of
something I'll say that a a division
youtuber Marco Styles found Marco came
up with a one-shot sniper built and he
said it took it didn't take him the ward
and a couple of hours to put together
you didn't got three of a particular
brand of three of his six gear slots of
one brand and in a model 700 now even a
good model several hundred a piece of
trash Model 700 bad rolls and he's in
there one-shot sniping guys it's based
off of having a couple of talents on his
three of history brands that worked
really well together and so you can come
up with a bill that can be able to you
know bring down those those manhunt
those man huh parties and I think also
something to know is that in this game
even though the map looks smaller than
the first game date the scale one the
one to what DC really looks like and the
size of DC compared to New York is a lot
better so it's like the map is actually
bigger than the New York match the first
game and the dark zones are bigger than
they appear
so as you're like sometimes you look at
you going in like that that dark sounds
not that big but then you start an
extraction and you think that you may be
able to get out there and stop a guy and
and and you know cut his rope and take
his gear and you may not be able to make
it in time so I would say give it a shot
my with me personally I have not played
one second of dawgzone or PvP
so
I've been so engrossed on all the hours
I've been playing this game so engrossed
and all the PvE aspects but I did play a
lot of it in the beta and man I had a
great time
I didn't I went rogue a couple times
just you know the really you know you
know have a little fun but there I could
give you one example of something that
think this and and this is as a solo
player I was in the dark zone tell me
what skills you're running in as a solo
player for a guy like he but what do you
feel is affected would you would you
have like a healing hive like give me a
skill use hit but I wouldn't use the
hive healer if you're a solo player I
would use the the Kem launcher
reinforcer mod when then is that it just
drops like a pellet and then they like
explodes into a little little green
cloud and heals your armor right there
on the spot it has a s right the
shortest cooldown out of any other
skills out there so if you and when I
use that when I'm playing solo now use
the hive healer well with a group is the
hive healer has a bigger you know area
range just kind of like the support
station for the night and if you heal
the group a bigger group of people you
can also point the the chem launch your
at other players and and it'll shoot
them and that will heal them but for the
most part it's really good to just hit
that bad that bumper or whatever you
have going on on your mouse a keyboard
and get that he'll really quickly that's
better to use solo in the dog zone in
PvP to kind of get yourself a little bit
of a boost as you keep fighting to get
the things the good thing with is that
the tanky guys who can't be shot down
because they're just you know they got
so much armor all that kind of stuff
that's that all that has been left
behind the first game they've set up to
the time it kills a lot lower and that
people can't expect their bill to be
unstoppable which is why there are a lot
of like big-time youtube I will call
them grievers and trolls who have a
platform on YouTube
who are now kind of complaining about
the dark zone not being what it used to
be because they think they start going
on manhunt and unless they know they get
shot out nowhere by a guy with a
one-shot sniper bill and necessary knows
that man hunts over are really being
able to dominate like the way they used
to is a little bit more fair and a
little bit more balanced and for
everyone to kind of enjoy the PvP and
not just the guys that know life the
game not you I'm gonna get Josh in
before we move on
Josh you've done any dark zone ever in
the division one orange no I didn't play
Division one so this is all brand new to
me
and so even just getting on board it was
probably a lot easier for for the rest
of you guys than me so no I haven't
touched the dark zone yet I am terrified
of the dark zone
I will stay firmly in the whites with
the Vanguard I mean look I'll wrap up I
know we definitely will be talking a lot
of division and stuff look it's a strong
first start you know that yes there's
some small minor gripes here in the air
who growing pains and balancing you know
but for the most part I agree with slow
just from a feature-rich standpoint
there's a is a lot to unpack there's a
lot to do you know and I just like from
a Loutre shooter standpoint it's gonna
it's gonna push destiny you know saying
like destiny bastards is proven that
they've listened to enough of the
complaints of the first game that you
know hey they're here you know we're
gonna address it then the main thing I
think they just need to do I'm dying to
know when the raid launches school we
know the world tier 5 is held back right
well what about you need George when is
that dropping we have a date on that we
don't have a date on that yet I'm kind
of suspecting it'll be sometime this
summer okay but they we don't have a
date on it yet and they did they didn't
do that for tier 5 they sent in their
stay in the game yesterday that
yesterday Wednesday that they wanted to
fix some of these little bugs that have
been popping up and like I said like the
skills bug you mentioned that popped up
on Friday of last week and then
had already had a fix and update for it
Monday and allows some of the other
little issues with like NPCs that you
need to speak to be in this era there I
go to the process of fixing all the bugs
first gotcha I'm pushing on to the the
next the next world tier which I suspect
should be out like in know next month
gotcha
what did raids look like in Division one
compared to like what we see in desert
hey okay so raid okay compared to listen
you have a six person raid you've got
you know stages of levels and bosses and
stuff like that
d1 they didn't exist Division one had
basically didn't have a raid they had
quote incursions as what they called him
and they were four person activities and
the first one is pretty much what turned
me off of the game it was this basically
a larger interior room there's an APC
like indoors
rockets every box basically like you had
a little hallway you're like hey you
shoot a couple enemies then you get in
this room and you're like okay so you
get like do all these waves of enemies
and then it's just they kept getting
harder and harder and crazy and crazier
and it's I know people obviously made it
easier after they got sets and things
like that but the way that things
started is rough so I actually don't
know how rate is going to be in d2 with
the eight people if they're gonna have
mechanics are they going to split you
guys apart they have potential with a
lot of stuff just because it is eight
people I'm just gonna be kind of curious
to see how that all works in you know
get actually live in action because if
they actually pay attention and listen
if and it depends on who they have build
the raids but also how realistic they
keep it so that's one of those things
I've seen in the videos and I called it
one point with Cognito as well it was
like what are we gonna have for like a
raid boss or something I said hey a big
helicopter and sure enough you see like
those big four bladed aren't like
personnel carrier helicopters but they
said that was almost more of a world
event that would like happen with one of
those out there not as much of a raid
boss so I'll be kind of curious what
they do in the airport actually so
that'll be interesting
yeah the I'm sorry
rate is a big thing for me I'm worried
because I have to agree incursions left
a bad taste in my mouth with division
one that in my opinion was not Indian
content and that's the thing destiny
will always in my opinion have over
division however when I did hear the
devs say with division to the commitment
to raid and shout out to Eric's gaming
you know saying home he had the dev on
and he pressed them when he said you
know are you gonna have a raid and he's
like is it gonna have you know how is it
you know he's gonna be like encouraged
and they were like no it's gonna be
mechanic base when I heard I'm like okay
now I'm wait he bounces also in that 8
players is a lot you know right now we
do inform force is I feel like is a good
spot you know um a that's a lot of
players so I don't know I don't know how
messy that's gonna get I agree with
shout to do mental to chat um if they do
something where they split you up maybe
and then maybe you come back together
almost think Josh almost like you know
eight player vault the glass in a way
that's a way well you know these old Dan
I could see it working but I am
skeptical of eight guys in a room like
that's a lot you know say I don't know
how do you think they could pull it this
is new territory for massive oh well
they have highly respected raids I mean
last wish is arguably one of the best
next to taking king and vaulted glass
arguably could be called the go and even
they're kind of average range so to
speak you know Raptor machine is beloved
you know crota is still below you know
so it's interested what do you think
slow what do you think they have to do
to hit the nail on the head with the
first division rate well I just wanna
say like I've you know I plays a lot of
destiny one and a good-enough
a little bit of destiny to hat and
that's how our core is you guys but I
think ball the glass of all the raids
I've done ball glass it's still their
best my opinion I've done all of the
origins and therefore incursions in the
vision one and the one he bounces
mentioned we just be by far the worst I
won this called Falcons loss and it's
basically a horde mode fifteen wave
horror mode which at the time when they
first came out if you got the way
fourteen and your group white you had to
start all over at the beginning it was
it was it was terrible it was by far
their worst one
no one willingly does that particular
activity unless there's like a reason to
do it you want to get an achievement or
trophy and playstation or something
that's the only reason why you do it we
talk about Falcons lost in here Falcons
loss is is is bad it's it's terrible
it's the worst thing they ever did but
they got better for each incursion the
next recursion was which was a lot
shorter and it was comedy air check you
had to have the the right level of gear
to be able to name great really really
good spec year in order to be able to
complete it but it could be it wants it
got to appointment people were
completing clear sky and like under five
minutes like know and like know why you
like that quickly and and and they
realize you know what we kind of went
too far in the opposite direction
because you couldn't complete Falcons
loss in under 45 minutes and now clear
sky three minutes this is now what we
need so I went the one I think is the
best the next one this uh Dragon's nest
it's awesome dragons nests has a lot of
like the mechanics that you become
before there's there's teamwork needed
you had to have kind of certain
strategies to take down certain certain
areas they add like four bosses they
call them the four horsemen that pop up
right in the middle of it that that
would be a complete gear check on your
group whether you can be even make it on
and I really really enjoyed that one the
best but the last one stolen signal it's
a lot like like a destiny raid there's a
lot of sessions to it there's a lot
it's a whole bunch of teamwork and a
whole bunch of like it'll be one section
where everyone has to pull out war to at
least two people have to pull out a
ballistic shield and to be able to
complete that section and be able to
defend other players as you guess you
complete the objectives it's it's really
good I didn't really enjoy it as much as
as dragons nests but it's I the way they
did stolen signal makes me believe they
they have a great idea of how to do and
they play a rate I'm not gonna say
guarantees gonna be like you know the
bee's knees the best thing ever but I do
I do know for a fact they understand how
you're gonna need to split this this
group up kind of have people do a couple
people here have to complete a certain
objective and other people have to do
other things that has to be so constant
cooperation and it's not yes guys
shooting guns and killing waves and
waves of enemies Krissy busting off and
I'm never gonna hear the end of it oh
thanks for that slow well yeah you know
we see what we see what the future holds
but um yeah man it's been really good so
far and we can't wait for worlds here
five to drop so I II owe at this other
game we gotta talk about what right now
at another game and uh people Bungie
stubborn but we gonna get into it like
yeah we got we got some opinions on the
twaf this week but for you guys as well
have been sucked into division you guys
been playing any destiny this is the
past week or two oh yeah I mean destiny
is so I guess let me back here my
brother is currently deployed and so I
play destiny who thinks that's kind of
the one way that we can kind of keep in
touch with each other so we play destiny
two to three times a week and like I
said I got my wife into it so she is
super pumped up and is always down to
play so yeah we play two to three nights
a week probably somewhere between five
and fifteen hours every week depending
on time so yeah I've been been really
working the grind on the season The
Drifter stuff and I am I have mixed
feelings I've mixed we go get to it
let's do this um let's hit the table
right Eve and then we'll get into
feelings I need so we were out last week
so I'm gonna blow through last week's
real quick just to get a quick recap
obviously thorns out there I don't know
if you guys have gotten the gun yet
anybody got it nah I haven't gotten it
but actually I found the quests
naturally I didn't actually know where
it was by reading online I found it over
the course of doing the allegiance quest
for The Drifter go on - oh yeah cause I
know there's one of those yeah makes
sense I can see how you did that which
was awesome like seeing the the massacre
the shadows by shin malphur was it was a
pretty great experience so I'm currently
I'm think I'm like - I - little bits of
content away from finishing the first
quest steps oh no but I'm psyched for it
and we serve more exotics than just hand
cannons I think it's all been here no
yeah it's ridiculous a mannequin cans
I know Bungie must love them more they
just have more lore something but yeah
there's other guns out there guys yeah
like I got the last word I don't need
another gang can pepper what about juice
no what about you slow-mo I have not had
a chance to get back on a this is gonna
be this is gonna sound terrible
I bought the season pass when the
information came out about gambit Prime
I'm like oh that sounds awesome
I'm in on that right so I get a season
pass and then I said you know what I'm
gonna be I'm gonna do when when the
division comes out I'm gonna do both of
these at the same time and yeah see the
boat part hasn't happened yet but I'm -
game before time who is has basically
been no life and destiny before really
giving into the division
Ashin Luca baby really kind of keeping
me up on everything and I'm like okay I
know what I need to do and and and
they're gonna be helping me out once I
can get my my gaming life balance back
so no I don't have anything at the
moment right now I'm uh I am definitely
a UH pretty far back when it comes to
getting uh the best weapons and yeah
I'll have it yet sorry you know one live
this life that I'm in man this is just
traffic I've taken we are so lucky that
anthem was bad
yes great man we all be in a bad place
right now
I feel bags I love warframe you know and
I and I have it and warframe is dropping
good content right now I'm just like oh
that sounds so good I'm not gonna play
it yet just like ma'am I feel like I'm
missing out but then it's like I don't
want to stop playing division so was Bey
like anthem dropping the ball uh thanks
I guess to breathe a blessing in
disguise for some what we got eat but
yeah I was like so there's one part of
it I'm waiting for basically and it's
the final strike that you've got to run
and the modifiers on that one are brutal
mm-hmm so take a singe make it all three
and make it only work against you really
yep and then there's also iron so the
guys are harder to kill and then
blackout so melee is hurt and you have
no radar it's all three of those working
against you on Sabbath oon song
Wow and you've got a couple giant
Knights to kill in the end and a couple
extra Shriekers and everything just
hurts so I tried it about 658 and I got
to about a midpoint but I was just like
I'm gonna wait cuz I do want to soul of
it I was like it's one of those things
just like that stupid you know challenge
I'm gonna put against myself but it's
gonna be real rough to do that so I
wouldn't advise that on anybody go find
a group work together be high level
don't make it harder on yourself into
because it is gonna be rough I think
you're your own worst enemy I know I'm
the I'm the crazy I was me like in
division or
new one when I was just like oh let's do
what was the Fallen saber strike solo
and be like oh this is a terrible idea
but no I'm this far and I have to do it
so it's stuff like that but I got a
shout out the shirt but I definitely
have to get so I've got to get the gun
to get the shirt because I love that
shirt it looks really really cool
so for thorne and get your replica and
then is anybody gonna get one of these
little uh jerseys for your gambit prime
that's where great it looks pretty high
yeah I think it's fire century
biochemistry I might go with that yellow
right there that's looking nice man
gotta love that invader life see that's
where I'm gonna end up because I'll be
playing with my brother and like they'll
be going along and I end up getting the
heavy and I'm like nobody else is gonna
go invade or you guys suck at invading
let me do it yeah that's not even help
my typical role but I'm like I guess I'm
gonna go try so so the way that our
fireteam ends up is that my brother just
like wants the most stuff down so he
land of just kind of guarding it kind of
lingering over near where you deposit
the motes but my wife she is a savage
when it comes to the motes if you would
take her motes he will never forgive you
oh yeah she wants every boat she can get
her hands on that electricity can drop
that big boy she gets livid when people
are taking their boats I fuel rage
killing you see all the glory on the
ground and then you just see somebody
run past you it's so yeah she will see
will black with you forever
and then I love the invading parts so we
actually kind of settled into the rolls
pretty nicely automatically it kind of
just worked out in a convenient way nice
what else we got E
so yeah those are definitely cool things
but to get them you have to get your
fold notorious set and then win a win a
match and my brothers like oh well my
boys want some it's like I'm gonna want
one so
I don't know if we're gonna be getting
two each but yeah I'm gonna be playing
some game to prime it seems like so I've
got my work cut out for me oh and then
was so the allegiance quest started last
week I know some you guys may have
jumped in picked the side we'll kind of
cover the next piece of how the
distinction went but what do you guys
think about the rewards of each so we've
got the Vanguard weekly package that you
get by pledging Vanguard one powerful
piece of gear boon to the Vanguard 10
Vanguard tokens but you get an
enhancement core and then drifter weekly
package you get a sense of each powerful
gear and a hundred infamy like how do
you guys feel like the weight of those
two weekly packages are and which one do
you think is like well one's probably
decent lore and more interesting what
you guys think about the what you guys
think about the weight of the packages
yeah on any side that don't have an
enhancement core I got a problem with
because we know we're gonna get into
cause with this soon as we update to
these twelve and yeah like you know
listen powerful gamma gears cool you
can't separate enhancement core to one
side they knew who people was gonna go
with the drift that's what that tells me
they do decide was very attractive so
they tried to through some sexy on the
van go outside and try to give out a
core because they know everybody needs
clothes but that's just my feel I don't
know what you guys I mean I could care
less like I'm in that allegiance quest
purely for the story aspects of it I
still have like 200 enhancement cores
from like year 1 of destiny so it's not
like a huge carrot on the stick for me
it definitely is for my brother and wife
though because they picked it up with a
low place it was forsaken so they're
kind of suffering under the enhancement
course but it's I mean for me the season
of the drifter is entirely a lore thing
not a gear thing at this point yeah
absolutely yeah that's what it's been
for me about you eat I mean for me I'm
with you it's just like they will get to
the enhancement core discussion a little
bit and I'll save my thoughts but it's
just like as that's one of those things
everybody's gonna use that's kind of
like that's a huge deal versus function
of collector since you just get by
playing matches and already have too
many of them anyway and they actually
had to
to make well you know kind of blow head
little extra but they literally made to
her oh you can trade in five cents just
for a hundred glimmer because you have
too many of them like so why is since
worth anything when you turn on and get
like powerful gear and you get a hundred
infamy which is like one bounty or a
week versus an enhancement core I know
it's one but your value of one
enhancement core is definitely better
personally than anything else on the
director side so it definitely seems
skewed for sure yeah absolutely
mmm and then we obviously Tier three
came out last week we had the people
going up against Oryx boiler alert but
tier 3 is there what did you guys think
though do you guys have any opinions the
fact that they're actually locking you
out even if you're 679 that you can't
get in there I would feel better about
it if the level requirement was lower or
the recommended light for it was higher
so basically like making it into an
exclusive endgame activity so if you say
the recommended light is 700 but we'll
let you in at 680 I feel like I don't
know like on the one hand I look at it
and say okay you're never going to get
match-made in with some what's reckoning
I mean that's a good thing for sure
right but on the flip side it doesn't
let us as a community decide what
challenge is right for us and like for
people like Yvonne sitters who you know
it's got to be just too badass while
badasses
so I don't know I I'm kind of a sweat
mind generally speaking I mean I'm not
680 yeah I'm early 6 70s and so I
haven't had a chance to go into
reckoning tier 3 yet do I want to
absolutely like I've heard that there's
some kind of interesting war stuff going
on in there but it's like it gives me
something to grind towards and besides
just like hitting that 700 cap so in
that respect I I'm fine with it
mmm because there is no rate for me to
grind up towards yeah by putting
kind of mint our requirement it means it
kind of it is the carrot at the moment
in a season that otherwise doesn't seem
to have a lot of them mm-hmm yeah I mean
I don't want to go too far into this
because a lot of what I'm gonna talk
about is gonna bleed into Coors and I
really want to save my core thoughts oh
yeah I'm gonna pass on my feedback on
this only for the simple fact
it literally is gonna be all about cause
you're gonna hear me rave so all right
so we'll go ahead and move on
invitations the nine first one really
cool yes I don't know if you guys got to
see it but heads up in you guys if you
did miss it you will not miss out as
long as you eventually do however many
there are going to be you will just see
yours and whatever weeks you play them
so even if you start three weeks in
you'll start on number one and you'll
get to see them all in order so no
worries about missing them if you
haven't seen the first one definitely go
get this stuff started but I will say
don't set your expectations that the
first one is gonna be that level every
time because they never cover that I
like that they go read my article on
lures of gaming done that exactly you
know I like that because I know you know
me personally I you know me that's thing
that being my main loot shooter at least
allows me to say you know I feel like
I'm missing all crap because I'm playing
something else I've been at my own pace
and be able to you know get all this
stuff complete and start from the very
beginning so I like that idea to me
vacuum only one what about what I like
about it is also to is that being it
you're playing the division right now
right so let's just say you didn't even
touch you know much of drifter at all
the cool part is you know now they can
on board you with some power surge
bounties now you know the minute you
jump in for the most part I believe if
you add that the appropriate level you
can get up to what is it about 640 you
know I'm saying guerrilla power boost
yeah yeah we're in about an hour and
that's something they never did before
and I like that catch up mechanic
because again the thing with these ludus
shooter games unfortunately you know if
you miss some time and you're behind
your friend it it's disheartening
sometimes you know you're busy shooting
you
bubbles they're people exactly but and
you come back good yeah
I did you the power boosters I have I
think I'm up to 650 something I got the
614 I did a little bit more with some
peeps I play with and I'm around 650
right now my warlock but they're
definitely not anywhere near like you
guys right now but um I do like the fact
that they're like hey look you know we
know that you may have taken some time
out you know here is a quick way to get
back up to speed and so that you don't
feel like because it gets kind of
moralizing and I've seen this in there's
a matter if it's destiny or warframe or
the division or just whatever game
you're playing you come back to again
and they've added all this new stuff you
just like what is it and then they end
it's like Oh what that's the power level
now don't worry near that and people
gets almost like - feeling people just
like you know what yeah I'm just not
gonna do it like that division maybe
they would introduce gear sets in
Division one people came back and was
like what's this green crap everywhere I
don't understand what this you know what
I'm done I'm just going back to destiny
so it's like yeah it's good to connect
you know find some ways to ease these
people back in so they gotta you know
just get caught up with everyone else
yeah so I mean for me the only thing
about those power boosts batteries of
the fact that they're only in the annual
past kind of hate but that's that way I
understand like there's more incentive
for you know having the higher level if
you're gonna go play stuff but then you
get an iron banner we'll get into that a
little bit as well but it's just like
for the average person be like hey I
kind of you know even want to catch up
with my buddies to go run a nightfall
with somebody as well it's like nope not
unless I get Daniel passed that's just
one of those little twinges I was like
just that's true Emmitt - everybody say
like I mean all they're doing is the old
stuff they're gonna be 6:40 but they
don't still get to do anything new but
at least somebody's jump in and they
want to play with their friends they're
like oh I'm about 500 here it was my
grind like let him jump in and gonna
play a little closer so yeah hey guys I
have do have to run that guy get to work
slow thank you for coming through
blessing us with that division knowledge
I I lean on you man when I need to learn
stuff I love the invitation I'm always
an avid listener listener to this
podcast you got me up SNe stuff and I'm
half of it goes over my head the other
I'm like oh snap I gotta get back on it
but regardless bounces I really enjoy
podcast with you today amen I'm good to
see you again
and incognito as well as you know bro it
is it's always a joy when you're around
much appreciated man and we're gonna do
this again you already know that oh yeah
Louie you know next time hit me up you
know especially I'm ready for that iron
Lords oh yeah oh you can't never direct
the red-carpet treatment you already
know that the trumpet blaring there's
gonna be rose petals on the copy
everything's goin down we're gonna do it
right and I'm bringing Forte as well
which we're gonna do a double feature
that sounds like a plan man you guys
have a great morning that everybody but
I dizzy have a great way I hope you get
diarrhea in traffic but you know but you
know though I'm sorry I did what you may
have a great onesies you can only say
that if you know somebody real good
where were we with the with the updates
man yeah so now we're on this week's 12
we'll catch up to kinda what's current
yeah we're looking at the calendar we
are we've seen most of what's gonna
happen outside of these general for
everybody things the revelry are queeg
those types of things are gonna be mid
you know early to mid-april a little bit
in May and that's gonna kind of wrap up
this season but right now we got
everything now I kind of want to ask you
guys your opinions on just the fact that
we do have everything and we're like
three weeks in there's not like
the drip-feed it's not a little slower
but now you've seen it all and now if
you kind of got there up quick what do
you guys think about your time in it
like how do you guys feel about this
season so far the way we've seen
everything go for it - I think this
season is kind of the opposite of the
black armory season for me and that the
black armory had milestones that were
spread out nice and evenly there are PvE
things which generally speaking I play
mostly PvE and so there was always you
know the next forge to be unlocked and
there was that kind of that I don't want
to say care to gang stuff like I said
that too many times but that next
activity on the horizon yeah whereas
with the season but the sorry but going
that's black armory the lore was pretty
terrible like there was the interesting
introduction of ADA right at the start
where she's like I hate guardians like
they don't you don't belong here that
kind of thing which I thought was really
compelling but then it kind of just went
by the wayside
and never really progressed into
something that I thought was worthwhile
to the overall destiny lore
whereas with season of The Drifter it's
the exact opposite like I love the 9 I
love The Drifter dredgen yor is so cool
shin malphur like all of this stuff is
awesome like I think that the growing
schism that's occurring between the
guardians on the side of the drifter and
Guardians on the side of the Vanguard is
so fascinating and something that I've
kind of been waiting for Bungie to do
for a long time is kind of build up kind
of a faction system that actually men
like things where you had faction
rallies but there's no difference
between dead orbit and new future war
cult and new monarchy like it's just a
name whereas here like I feel like
destiny has a potential to really do
something interesting and there were
those leaks about destiny 3 potentially
having you know siding play on the door
and I don't know if this is lead into
that or what the endgame is here I mean
I predicted that the end game was going
to be you and shin malphur and the
shadows of you are all standing yeah
Mexican showdown on twin there's Ridge
whoa given some of the revelations about
shin malphur that might not actually end
up being the case but I
it didn't take us somewhere interesting
the question is how quickly will Bungie
follow up on its considering that the
season of opulence is going to be the
next season and that looks like it's a
return to kind of the year one destiny
questions that are lingering with Calais
and the - I don't know like Bungie seems
reticent to solve more mysteries in a
timely manner and so but I'm along for
the ride
like I think the invitation of the ninth
of every week is so interesting I think
it's a cool evolution of what they did
with the Queen's courts throughout
Forsaken and so the lore is really what
I love about destiny in addition I mean
obviously the gunplay is fantastic but
the lore is the carrot that keeps me
there it is again but but that is that
is why I continue to be invested and
engaged in the game is all the different
layers of story that they have and are
able to tell and I think that's why I
may not become interested in what
continues : with anthem and what is
gonna go on with the division is that so
far their lore is not compelling and
Destiny's since then has been Jack so
weird and full of mystery and it just
Bungie is so good at getting you to come
along just a few more steps and a few
more steps and a few more steps and I
think season adjuster has been fantastic
with that it's like I can't wait til sir
shows up I get off work and mmhmm three
hours and so I'm gonna go home and
immediately go find sir and get you mean
you're gonna immediately watch you
bunches this video and that's what you
really meant to say nah man because the
editors at Lords of gaming take take
like a couple hours
yeah I gotta get my piece rain okay oh
listen let me jump in on this um this is
interesting because I'm conflicted with
seasons in Egypt it's just a weird thing
like the gameplay loop between Prime and
reckoning is okay I don't mind it you
know I'm saying but after the second is
you know third run of it you
oh it's like okay mmm you know I'm
saying so I have I have a little issue
with that the thorn quest dropper now
that was an immediate carrot on a stick
you know everybody's gonna hit the
ground running with that the tremendous
lure of the gun and what-have-you for me
my treat is literally like I said it's
Friday's it's an invitation to the nine
I want to know more and I thought that
was really well done
like I really enjoy you know I'm saying
finding out you know I'm not gonna spoil
it but backstory right and I didn't know
what was going on
I liked that drifter felt away about us
finding out what's going on hey Bill I
thought that was well done so that's
been my little carrot on the stick so
this week like I want to know every week
nothing we're gonna find out in the next
coming up in the in the which was at
swab you know not necessarily all the
time it's gonna be the same way but um I
think this is cool because the nine are
mysterious you know you want to know
what the intent is all you want to know
more about drifter in what's going on
with that aspect so literally what I
thought division would completely peel
me away the law aspects of the line as
well as picking the side of the Vanguard
or the drifter is what's keeping me
coming back can we just say that the
voice actor for the drifter who I just
looked up his name Todd haberkorn
he's awesome yes good like by far the
best voice acting of any character who's
not awoken in the game like my resolve
and I love Aldrin but man like he is
just fascinating to watch individual
acting in that first cut scene that we
see in laughs that we saw Gnostic
sensation at 9:00 so good oh good he is
he is and to be in it is defenseless
that's a great point because let's be
real like II mean you've had discussions
about you know the Kay death the impact
and Kate was beloved right yeah like yes
and let's be real like triptych honest
in that spot and like I'm not gonna say
I don't miss Kay but sometimes I forget
the sake of just is so intriguing to me
like I've been away do you want to go go
go go go for it mom so something that I
was actually literally thinking about
earlier today because I wouldn't looked
up those fats that they post it up last
week and I wonder what the split would
have been between Vanguard and dresser
if Kaede was still alive because one
thing that I think is been really weird
is how sideline Decorah has been
basically the entire time yes like she
just sits in the not even in the annex
but in the little side region where it
doesn't do anything and Zavala is more
involved and engaged but like I feel
like destiny too has really kind of not
made the Vanguard into interesting
people in a way that like they focus so
much on the drifter and I thought that
Hawthorne was gonna take a bigger kind
of step forward but even she is now
totally sidelined and so I kind of want
to see a bit of a redemptive arc for the
Vanguard in making maybe not redemptive
but a reinvigoration of the Vanguard as
characters that you look up to and that
you aspired it like towards and like I
don't know I want them to be cool again
like and like I don't feel like you're a
Korra
Orr's of always particularly cool right
now but The Drifter is hella cool I mean
yeah I was like you guys said a lot and
covered a lot of the pieces - it's like
the voice acting is cool but yeah it's
like ifs of all ahead you know stepped
up and like alright let's go get it i
Kors like cool we go home after this
visions you would have a different feel
for the Vanguard and be like okay
they're gonna step up take care of their
fallen brethren drifter comes in but
he's got these interesting things I kind
of with you like if cave would be alive
or if that that art didn't have it then
everybody was like Cevallos kind of
being a turd right now like if that
aspect of it didn't have happened and a
lot of people were just like dude I got
burned by Zavala he just
you know he whipped out on us and then
you got the drifter coming and getting
this little lake you know mystery about
him of course everybody's gonna go that
direction it makes it almost an easier
choice because we don't know we're gonna
go down this path and you have a choice
that makes sense and in the vanguard as
you said I mean dizzy said in Chad he's
like the vanguard currently or
complacent they're just kind of chillin
in Tower they're holding it down they
know the Guardians do their thing they
haven't been driven they haven't had
those moments where like as well as like
get with me and like Pops's bubble and I
Corps is like just like smashes the ship
and just kind of goes it we haven't had
but one of those moments and then
they've just been sitting on their
perches again sacks we get to a point
where we've been bored of the drifter or
not bored of the drifter bored of the
Vanguard you can we have history we have
this guy that's got back story could be
good could be bad like house not gonna
do that
of course you are souls like the first
character for sure you might do a second
about just to see the other side but the
first one seems a lot more compelling
and intriguing with the drifter with
ease there doesn't it doesn't feel like
they set both of them up to be
compelling I haven't gone down the drift
the Vanguard path I will but just in the
setup at least it doesn't seem like it's
got a chance so here that was
interesting in warm line that they set
up that I think we could bring back in a
compelling way is Anna Bray yeah for who
she was prior to becoming a guardian and
I think that could be an interesting way
to I guess get into some interesting
things with the Vanguard is going and
looking and finding who's of Allah and I
Cora were before they were Guardians
and I think they're compelling stories
there that could bring them around in
kind of a major way mmm no absolutely
man I agree good stuff man
what else we got oh yeah so I mean for
the rest of the season we've got one
more map next week all the private
matches load up on April 2nd the
following week and then finally we do
get our two pieces for everybody
annual pass or not we've got art week
Ark week which some everybody is what no
one knows what the hell that is
you know we joked about it before every
podcast you listen to that's just like
is it just arcs inch everywhere or
everybody just follow it that week use
your main ingredient and then your
kinetic and your gut like so I wonder if
the ark week is going to
into either The Reckoning or what's
going on on the drifter ship and like we
are charging something up mmm see really
that's my fear is that it's a is a world
event that takes place with every single
Guardian and you have to every Guardian
combined has to get you know a million
art kills or whatever it is over the
course of a week and doing that charge
is something in the directorship see
that's what that is but of course the
writer coming in with the creativity the
game right there you go let's go we got
the revelry which looks like it's gonna
be longer event like we had you know
this one's gonna be another three-week
event it looks like so we definitely
have some more time to spend in the
spring forest little brighter colors it
looks like and that will be coming April
16th of May 6 but those are the general
ones for everybody but we've basically
seen everything I was like we've talked
about before so yeah we don't need to go
through it all but it's just kind of
interesting now that now that we all
have it there's not really rush for
anything you said there's no raid to
grind up for and tear through is just
gonna be waiting until I get there I'm
687 so I mean if I found a couple I'd
probably potentially be able to do it it
very much depends on the rolls of the
day I can tell you that if you go they
took glass out thank God mm-hm
glass was brie and they did put prison
back in it prison back in to give it
another memorable rotation but if you
have a bad roll on that day just me I'll
be like nope not gonna do it that day
which is kind of an interesting thing
for an indie game piece of gear piece of
content to say how are my modifiers
today they suck never mind like that is
kind of disheartening for some days be
like hey I got everybody coming in
what's the random roll for Friday oh
okay what else that's why I said it's
for that that's why it's such a mixed
bag for me because the content loop is
not necessarily what I'm here for I'm
actually here for the narrative aspects
there yeah it is what it's a weird spot
is so uneven for me like I really want
to go in on it but then I'm like damn I
like the drifter I like the lord and I
love this the 9 there but necessarily I
don't like looking forward to the
terrible I don't necessarily like
grinding ramble prime all the time or
so so cog we're saying is that maybe it
might be helpful to have some kind of
tests or trials that related upon hope
and another reason that got me excited
and he knows I've said it you know at
nauseam is the fact that the nine are
away from trials and they in in gambit
stay over there
you know the yeah man like that that's
what I'm hoping for it I again shout out
to you Josh she had a great article in
reference to the things I believe um you
know just theories in general what you
think could happen you know I'm saying
as far as um where this season is going
in who you think things might be leading
up and I like the fact that you you said
my boy um it's I'm happy
hey I have zero doubt that character
reference is Osiris by the emissary than
I am last week the other one is is much
more up in the air but I could I'm I'm
leaning towards it being rescuing just
to kind of tie back into what happened
over the course the last year in destiny
but I would love who's Eris morn she's
my girl
Bri my see you in a chat we would
literally talk about what you're saying
he said scream said he's working on a
theory on who the infinite hourglass and
the old knife sharpened a new do me a
favor scream put in the check can you
tell us who you think those two are
because literally that's the article
that Josh wrote and he gave his theory
into him who he thinks those two are and
to put that in have a great yeah so I
think I think it makes sense for it to
be rescue in the old knife obviously
rescue news from the the Golden Age and
it was forgotten for a really long time
and then real woken recently so it's
been free char Bend if you want to go a
little more literal in terms of blades
if we think all the way back to the
taken King at the end of it after
defeating Oryx Eris morn who was a
non-fire character it was fairly
prominent in Destiny one but we haven't
seen her in Destiny - she takes Oryx his
sword at the end of Destiny one which to
me indicated that she was taking control
of the taken via the sword logic she was
taking the throne that you left empty
that hasn't seemed to be picked up on
destiny - it seems like savathun and
quria blade transform are the ones who
are taking control of taken since oryx's
throne has been left empty at least
that's what's indicated by the dreamy
city but whether that holds true who
knows when we'll see that mmm
interesting the dairies gonna go and
this is this like I said it's the
narrative right now that's keeping me
it's in a good place but we got a lot of
time to get into squares happening uh so
iron banner returns with double Valor so
Mike's got a little extra Valatie isn't
working on that in the coming week and
we've actually got some modifiers this
time or how this is gonna work
you got iron burden and wolf's favour so
iron banner is one of the few playlists
where power level matters to some extent
it never feels totally drastic but to a
point it does give you an advantage or
disadvantage depending on how far part
in a level despair - you are so if
you're like seven hundred somebody else
is like 621 you're likely I'd have an
easier time to kill that person now what
does that do for the average player
who's like hey I just got into it and
I'm like six on and I'm like five eighty
oak crap there's 700 people out there so
they want to try and make it to give you
a reason to kind of equalize or level
the playing fields or maybe just take
the PvP world and make a little harder
upon yourself so they've got two things
coming in they've got the iron burden
and wolfs favor iron burn who's gonna be
the consume basically it's just gonna be
a way to challenge yourself and drop
your light level by a hundred pretty big
drop like if you ever look at their
little power graph they did eons ago a
hundred is a pretty sizable drop in your
damage that you output and also how much
you're gonna take so it's definitely
going to change up how it feels for sure
it's gonna take five hour and bannon's
iron banner tokens to purchase one but
if you do grind one out and I know
you've been waiting for this one because
I this is like one years that you've
said before if you finish a burden by
defeating five hundred opponents while
the iron burden debuff is active you
will be rewarded with an updated version
fully masterwork curated role wizened
review oh yes my baby that is your baby
I was like I remember you saying it's
like I got my y's and like I know the
that was your like that was your goatee
for a little while Wow it's tough now
because you know what sucks because I
have loaded question I got to see how
you know the curated role is but
literally loaded question has finally
dethroned I closed in my energy slot s
shotgun because I closed would never be
able to get out but then since the
trench barrel broth I mean nerf and then
um you know HS not that is not good it's
still good but it's just wisent it's so
effective in so many situations and like
especially gambit strikes that explosion
damage is so big and then it you can
still do boss DPS with it it's really
but shout out the whys every Brook I'm
gonna give it a shot you know maybe but
also what was gonna ask what do you
think of like hey your new curator to
roll your master work for granting out
500 kills which is not a small number
for one with the debuff which will make
it even harder on you is an updated use
like a master work dear one thing do you
think that's a fair reward do you think
there should have been a little more
creative I think the way I 500 is a lot
and we Leslie yeah that's like that's
not no easy task
killing 500 people with this you know
basically self nerf you know so to speak
I like the idea of the self nerf because
I feel higher level eyes you know need
something some other incentive you know
I'm saying and then you know it's what
the iron band has always been
controversial with that whole power
level thing I like it you don't saying
but then again you some people that you
know they feel like it's unnecessary I
think this allows them to play with it
you know the reward I mean even though
I'm a fan of wizard prison reboot I
don't know if necessarily that's gonna
you know galvanize the base do this is
not another hand cannon we gotta see I
mean I like the idea of it I don't know
if I'm sold on the rewards and the
investment that that's where I'm at
right now
sorry enough about you Josh
um I'm not a big fusion rifle fan I like
just like shotguns or sniper rifles in
my seconds
I'm currently I have a pretty God rolled
bat Lander that I absolutely adore this
and then I use I close - when I'm doing
PvP stuff but I don't know I mean 500 is
a lot and like over the course of
playing iron banner I just like is more
crucible like I want to see iron banner
evolve into something more interesting
like what if it was well no I have an
idea of what if iron banner was like a a
tournament basically over the course of
the week and so at the end of its like
the top third players they get some
reward the middle third players get some
reward and the bottom third of players
get some reward for participating and so
the matchmaking is basically putting you
against players to determine your
overall ranking just like I don't know
something but for now I mean iron banner
is just more of the same crucible with
power levels in it so there's there's no
incentive for me to go and do this like
sure having another gun great but like I
already have one I don't need a fully
master word version of it's because I'm
never going to use it anyways if I'm
gonna use the fusion rifle I'll pull
Telesto out like I don't know why it's
it's not a big enough incentive for me
to care about iron banner beyond the 5
matches I'll play to get my power for
rewards what about you E is that uh
enticing you I know you and then
crucible guy like that no I mean I'll
play some here and there I've had some
funds like I dabbled in the tiniest bit
of comp actually working on the thorn
quest just cuz it moved the bar a little
quicker and I had somebody playing with
me so that helped a little bit but he
has liked it I had better as you were
even even before like there were
different they would be different modes
maybe it was iron banner mayhem or iron
banner controller it has been control
since d2 launched it is the same thing
it's yeah I was like wore black Jackson
give us combined arms give us larger
Maps give us some reason to
apart like I'm with you Josh for sure
and then the other side you have this
wolves favor we'd take like lower-level
people you bump them up a max of a
hundred up to seven hundred for thirty
minutes so it's pretty short I mean how
many matches is that three maybe maybe I
thought steroids lasted longer than that
but I was like it kind of depends but it
was like losing his mind over there but
you've also got a chance to get the drop
from into the daily story vanguard
strikes night falls flashpoints gambit
weekly milestones you can't even go buy
it for like glimmer or shards or
anything you gotta go go do the other
content that you're doing anyway it's
like yeah it's like hair do this while
you level up a little bit and we'll give
you one of these things to go have a
boost in iron banner it's like it take
it you gotta go spend time in PvE just
to try and get your boots for PVE pvp
it's like they I don't know the
disparity between those two seems it
feels like a weird concession yeah I
mean at the end of the day I still like
it I mean I'm biased I'm a you know say
so I mean leave something to do you know
to see it oh well I guess you said the
PowerSearch boundaries are only for
annual pass holders yes okay I was gonna
say it feels weird that it's a hundred
level increase if you can power surge up
to 640 but if it's just for an your
password so I can see why okay I mean
okay I mean for me although I do like
iron banner I do like the unique control
ask because it's a different control I
love that the three lockdown system when
you get all three points you know is it
still right now yeah I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna lie to you I'm not gonna say
like oh you know you know it's so much
different than anything else I can see
what you're saying he is far as variety
they probably do need to introduce you
know other modes within it it's just
that the community loves control so much
that even though we say it if they do it
I can see the minute they do uh I gotta
play clash oh you don't say like I
remember when people love control that
much you know so we gotta steam but I I
agree something probably needs to be
added to spice it up
yeah so we've got the to the ups and the
downs we'll see how that goes next week
good luck grind in your 500 but if you
got read Rick's hello I got there you go
what if they put iron banner pinnacle
weapons so yeah it's a weapon only
through the iron banner season yes I'm
rich on it but they don't have but
that's what it's like I don't think the
wizened rebuke is gonna be quite at that
level with its own unique perk it's just
gonna be a masterwork probably you know
maybe faster charge time rangefinder and
you're you got a fusion rifle like it
needs its own thing so that'd be cool
that'd be nice armor sets will shown on
screen but do you guys do you guys what
I mean okay thank you I mean kognito
yesterday like I've liked previous ones
I like that yeah I like that Titan set I
think that's heightens that looks pretty
cool I too look pimp that's about the
only one I like I do not like the hunter
cape from like the neck up was cool with
like the kind of a sheen around the head
what poor luck I was like honestly for
both three of these I haven't felt like
iron banner sets have been distinct from
other seasons they're all variations on
everything from dusty - yeah I agree so
those will be there we've got so I guess
this will be maybe the wise and rebuke
in iron banner form they also mentioned
they updated a version of or wings mall
with random roles so that'll be kind of
in the rolls as well for iron banner
this time that's the single-shot grenade
launcher right yeah no it needs to
offering a new emblem you'll be able to
pick up it'll try it and this one will
track your higher power opponents defeat
it in iron banner so at least you can
see your progress with the new emblem
hopefully it doesn't cost too much to
pick up well that pretty much wraps up
iron banner and this is gonna be the
main topic of the day so before I open
my big mouth not big mouth but before I
open my mouth at all March Madness
brackets that's the big day yeah that's
totally one hundred
March Madness brackets unfortunately my
team my school's probably not gonna make
it to the end so I even had a bet
against K you this year but all that
being said enhancement course now they
are a point of contention between
different people different levels of
players casual streamers all those
different things everybody's got
different opinions but the infusion
system is one of those things a lot of
people have an issue with so I'm gonna
read this out just so everybody on the
podcast can hear this thing and then I'm
gonna go Josh first then Cognito than me
so I can kind of save my thoughts for
the end so I'm gonna read this just
verbatim cuz I want everybody here all
the pieces I'm gonna pause at certain
points you guys can let certain things
happen as well because it needs to be
like it this needs to be heard from
bungees perspective and i want to know
why so the conversation around
enhancement cores here's the best they
need that team the goal of the infusion
system is to create an impact that would
have thanks bro sorry physical yeah go
for it go for it so the goal of it the
infusion system is to create an
impactful feeling of progression when
you increase the power of an item you
enjoy using an infusion system with no
scarcity around the materials would
diminish this impact to that end we
tapped into a material with inherent
scarce Ness enhancement course which
used to have a different name as well
these to be master recorders that not
just add to that in to use as one of the
keystone materials for this process this
is the goal of the infusion system but
if the overall system is causing a
negative experience we want to work to
improve it long pregnant pause there
we're constantly monitoring the infusion
economy to see what kind of impact it
has on gear usage we keep a close eye on
the amount of infusion materials being
earned versus how many are being used
and we'll continue to make adjustments
as needed to that end we'll be making a
change in season of opulence with the
goal of providing more access to
enhancement course scrapper bounties
previously dropped from dropped randomly
when dismantling gear there was no
reliable way to earn enhancement cores
using these bounties and we didn't feel
they were providing enough
materials we will be deprecating these
bounties at the start of season seven
parentheses note that any unfinished
scrapper bounty is still in your
inventory at the new season can be
completed before they naturally expire
in their place the gunsmith will now
offer a selection of daily and weekly
bounties that can be purchased from four
gunsmith materials it has what this has
what the scrapper bounties each of these
will include among other things in
enhancement core as a reward fork as a
reward when completed our hope is that
this increased access and control over
enhancement core acquisition will help
improve the balance of materials being
earned versus materials being used as
always will be continuously monitoring
this item economy along with your
feedback to assess its effectiveness
so now Josh you can come back to the
world thanks for mutant for a second I
know we're catching you and uh catching
you in a tough spot but thanks for
joining us either way but yeah so all
that being said a lot of thoughts now
before I say anything else okay so yeah
I can give my thoughts real quick and
then I actually I have to run so I'm
gonna gonna miss the fireworks
we'll get your thoughts in here first so
I think this so Bungie is in a tough
spot because what they want to have
happen is they want new gear to draw for
players they want players to put that
gear on test it out see if they like it
and if they don't put that gear into
things they already do like like that is
fundamentally what Bungie wants to have
happen in terms of gear now the problem
is that enhancement cores are a bad idea
they're they're too rare and like I I
have a hundred and fifty some enhancing
course but I don't want to spend them
because why would I upgrade my whisper
when I know that you know in two more
hours I can upgrade it by you know ten
more light levels like so then I just
I'm always locked in this this
perpetuating cycle of never wanting to
upgrade anything because the next thing
is coming so I have an idea for a fix
mmm let's hear it so too
people to try out new things but also to
bring along their old favorites so I say
scrap enhancing car is all together but
if you want to infuse gear put it on a
timer so you can only infuse your gear
once a day or once every two days or
once every three days or some some
length of time so then it's okay I got a
new piece of kit like I can decide to
infuse it into so I get a new rifle put
it into whisper I bring whisper up great
now I can't put new gear into whisper
for at least a day so that means if
there are new piece of gear that job I
will have a chance to try them out
before I then go and raise whisper up
but then I don't feel like I am wasting
time by always enhancing whisper
thunderlord or we go in or whatever
you're your gun of choices so it then
becomes a choice of okay when do I want
to upgrade this not should bring in some
of those free to play you know chests
like I'm putting on like you can only
infuse once a day is interesting I'm in
a minute I got it I mean all that this
is it first of all if you got a run roll
let me give you a big out thank you so
much for coming through man knowledge
Lord knowledge destiny knowledge one of
the best young writers in the game well
what websites you're writing for John so
I'm ready for Lords of gaming nets I'm
not sure if you've heard of it's a kind
of a young up-and-comer it's got a
pretty good height man noise so I'm
currently doing weekly pieces on the
invitations of the nine and what goes on
with that including various lore
speculations and then starting today
I'll be working on sukira shadows die
twice and I'll have a review for that up
sometime in the next couple weeks
nice man Josh a pleasure you know we got
to bring you back also we got to get you
at the coffee shop nah man I'm at a pub
I'm in the UK there's
I'll respect you for doing that right
there you gotta go but you will you
definitely will be back and we will
continue more destiny lore discussions I
mean thank you so much last time
absolutely yeah I'm gonna put this
article in there so you guys can check
it man guy is really great young writer
he really knows his destiny lore like
like a little mini bike holding me back
that's why I sent you over this you can
adopt you guys take it easy
thanks happening so yeah it's one of
those things where it's like look course
initially I didn't have a problem with
first okay I see what hey will okay stop
it right there what were they called and
what were they used for oh man it was it
and when they were master workhorse
mm-hmm yeah it would if I remember um it
wasn't just part of the infusion process
kind of similar what it was in the heart
of the master working process right
right yeah correct correct
Mowgli only right oh he's feisty about
this he's ready it's gonna I feel the
last word gun big [ __ ] towards my
loading loading it up right now
listen [ __ ] you bought this malphur I
mean it without your you're absolutely
correct it was just for that purpose all
right then soon as the Forsaken came
then we got you know this whole new bit
of now instead of just you know level up
gun you require max workhorse and I
think the thing that is also getting
missing from this is the additional
materials you need you need a primer and
you need legendary shards right so now
leveling these weapons you know makes
you you're depleting yourself of three
resources and one of them being
masterwork or enhancement coins are very
rare right exactly
so that's when I again I didn't
understand the system I started it and
the next thing you know I am draining
running through cause and it became bad
and the main issue I have
is that I understand that I'm trying to
want to stop powerleveling but he's the
fundamental problem and shout the
poetess because we know he's on this you
know I'm saying here I literally spread
this and I was like I literally went to
his Twitter I was like all right what
did he say and I was yeah it didn't take
long
yeah Paul TAS he's been on it man and um
I think the biggest offense to me is one
I can't look
how I want and play with what I want
based on this system on this system you
in order to survive in order to be
efficient you really kind of gotta take
what's given at the higher light you
know I'm saying somebody because of the
you know the whole thing and then that
the more important thing is you know now
they're talking about you know we have
spider as our resource six boundaries or
what have you you know fine you blow
through those then you have the scrapper
brownie which I do agree I agree with
their thought process that it's not a
reliable way because yes it was random
we never knew when you're gonna get his
crap about it you just dismantle
something and boom here or you finished
something and boom here it pops up and
it's very random so that wasn't a
consistent thing I don't have an issue
with them necessarily giving Banshee
functionality the question for me is
gonna be how many bound is he has from
what we're hearing right daily and
weekly you know it's just one core per
right now they very specifically had
enhancement core not course exactly so
again I don't wanna blast banshee all
the way until I see it but from how it
sounds it still sounds minimal right so
let's say you scrapper bounties that
week I mean no stupid no mo scrap but
you do spider bounties that week you get
your five or six you do um you know
whatever how we don't even know how many
let's just say he has four you know I
don't let's say yeah I don't know let's
say is three what is it to dailies or
the weekly who we don't even know right
then that's it
you're still depleted of a necessary
resource for levelling like it is just
too scarce you know and I want to shout
Tassie I believe I'm gonna say no I want
to shout Rick cactus cuz um cactus had a
video out
and he made another suggestion and he's
like why don't they tie it to powerful
loot drops like you know you do your
powerful gear for the week why can't
there be a set amount hey if I do my
three gambit matches you get you two if
I do crucible you don't say especially
crucible give crucial people something
but um again it's just a flawed system
but here's is my last point I'll give it
to you guys I know I know I bought this
mouth for an Ironman Cumberland is the
date this is the bungee lately that I've
been concerned about and that's why I
put it in my title is budgie stubborn is
because we just been through the trials
Fiasco right and everybody's like yo we
love 3v3 elimination we love trials how
it is and budgie comes back and say we
know what's best for you it's not that I
got a problem with that I have a problem
with that it's it's basically we are
being shut down with Korres in the same
fashion we're being shut down how we
were shut down with trials the community
does not want this I mean for the most
part outside of what may be good valiant
like I can't think of many popular
destiny streamers or community members
that are just so infatuated with the
core system they definitely need to be
tweaked and again I just don't like this
attitude of you know this is how it's
gonna be
we're not gonna remove them we're gonna
tweak but the jury's out man I'm trying
to give them the benefit of the doubt
with this Banshee thing before I truly
go ham I know you about to go in but it
just feels like they don't want to budge
on this core thing man they just digging
in the ground and with games like
division out and ant them trying to
research or whatever whatever it's only
so many times you gonna keep pissing
people off with things that they love
and you're kind of in a Content I don't
say content drought but in a drip-feed
kind of state right we would annual pass
this is not the time to be telling your
community no
you don't I'm saying like this is really
not the time you know saying we had slow
on he's a hundred percent invested in
individual I know people who at least
have from my clan date they're they're
over here now they may come back for the
Lord stuff but again in the past we've
always blamed Activision evil Activision
damn it why don't they let Bungie do
what they want maybe he's starting to
see some stuff that we know about I am
done II he bought this mouthful last
word is good alright so I'm gonna take a
big giant breath because I'm gonna say
on this one there we go alright so I
have a couple different opinions on this
being coming from multiple people's
perspectives mine being a giant hoarder
and I have a butt ton of these things
and I'm still not a fan of this system
you have different levels of people out
there take my brother for example he
grinds the crap out of a lot of stuff
but he doesn't isn't just swimming in
course because he didn't save him up
when they were quite as popular and I
also stored him up before we had to
infuse everything so whether I have
three hundred and thirty whether my
brother has twenty first you got a thick
picture the Ottoman economy we have in
the purpose where they started was
masked working just weapons first off so
they had a purpose you were going to
take a weapon you were gonna say hey
I've spent some time with this weapon I
love the roles I got on it I want to
take it that one perk that's on their
own a take it to the next level cool
you're gonna spend this currency this
limited resource to take this one piece
of gear what be a weapon first armor
came later and take it to that next
level so say the hey this is an
important thing to me I want to use it
as my build cool and that's a good thing
like that's a way to take your gear and
give it depth give it an investment give
it something more to get into it okay
that's what they were intended or at
first then when forsaken came out we had
the name change and that they got to
later cuz it was now they changed the
use of it before they even changed the
name master workhorse to infuse and
you're like what the hell is this so
they have this weird dichotomy if you
take a game like anthem you take a game
like Diablo even you get a new piece of
gear
and say an anthem if I go do you know
working on some stuff and I'm still if I
get a master work at level it went on
level 30 it's always gonna be like that
what's master works right now and
they're 45 say it's 45 powerless say
that's what all maths works drop at and
that's what they cap at but I get all of
my stuff at that yes I even get my blues
my rares so that's the equivalent piece
of destiny dropping everything whether
it's a blue whether it's a legendary
whether it's an exotic everything would
drop at 700 if I'm 700 that doesn't
happen so you have random roles of which
whether I want master work whether I
want say I want a machine gun build cool
hey I get you know loaded questions just
like you got okay I'm gonna find out I'm
gonna get these pieces of armor cool I
got some that have mass fusion rifle
scavenger fusion rifle reserves and all
those pieces okay that's my build for
fusions like you can start making builds
but most of the gear that you get in
this game is about twenty powers levels
below what you are or 18 whatever that
weird-ass number is you get it below the
level so when you're looking for all
these random roles they're not all
dropping at 700 for right correct you
get your random pieces so then you have
to spin now you have to spend cores on
these random roles to get them back up
to where they started and then you have
to spend cores to get them to be that
specialized piece of hey I got this
piece of armor it's machine gun reserves
and machine gun you know
dexterity or whatever those two pieces
aren't awesome I want to use this a lot
I'm gonna master work it that takes
cores the same currency on top yes now I
went through and did the math and this
is what just pissed me off more than
anything too so if you want to have
builds okay so I say I want to go
machine gun reserves yeah and I want to
go
pulse rifle that's gonna be like my helm
my class item my chest piece maybe my
boots like most of my armor can tie into
most of my weapons and weapons therefore
are certain choices so I'm gonna have
I'm gonna go figure pulse rifle I'm
gonna have my hammer head and I'm gonna
have say my loaded question fusion rifle
if I want to take a set of eight pieces
armored in gear and weapons and master
work the whole thing's and I love this
build 96 course Jesus Wow Aventine to
fully max each weapon it's nine to fully
max a piece of armor hold disclosure I
have never Master worked a piece of
armor and less literally until the other
day just to see how much it cost
well I'm glad you said that because that
was a point that I missed and um you
made you're killing it he because at the
end of the day I've never a master
worked in armor I didn't even see the
functional that's a benefit I didn't
feel it was that worth it for me to be
giving away this precious resource you
know I'm saying for one piece that and
here's the other thing that when the
next content drop comes out you're gonna
be doing this all over again
so exactly not the problem right they
they've got to lower the price of
admission on master working like there's
no incentive the only thing now because
remember master work was a cool thing
right it was a relief before they became
enhancement course right shout-out to
the dude he's like 96 good good yeah he
bought his job in he's got a fax like
before they changed it from master work
to enhancement the master work process
was a cool thing right you got the gun
now multiple kills you get in orbs right
so this was something like oh wow this
is a really cool functionality and added
thing now you throw it you know I'm
saying into you know enhancement cores
and all of a sudden I mean these tears
now you're telling me you know you
support is it 14 / 17 for a weapon 17
per weapon 9 per piece of armor that is
insane there is not enough of the
resource around even if you did you and
I'm saying like your spiders
consistently and you just keep you know
you're just holding on this is not
enough it's not enough resource for it
and at the end of the day they still
have to change the system and I just
don't know why they're digging a line
and the sand on this this makes no sense
to me like I don't get it man and I'm
concerned I'm concerned this is this is
again round 2 love daddy
Pongo knows best I'm not I'm not feeling
it bro because it's like this can
done way better this can be done way
better you can bring the cost down now
we hearing from banshee that he's gonna
want what is it gunsmith materials right
yep we had the discussion off-air me and
you about gunsmith materials because
guess what ADA right who now her she has
a special role and that she gives you
mod components right no she wants some
gunsmith materials 25 each
she's the only resource for that again
why do they have such limited people to
get resources or limited ways to get
things they've got it they've got to do
better and we still have to stick with
this current thing until season seven
like shut up to uh the dude this and to
check him and him in a piccolo from
tower talk they were talking about that
like literally this doesn't even happen
right now right
weird season of opulence work it what
two months away so they that again
where's the this is what I like about
the anthem in the division in a sense
that the proactive nature the agility of
jumping in quick depicts patch boom why
do we have to wait two months just for
this semi average kind of solution let's
be real right I don't know man I'll let
you I'll let you finish it off but the
this very concerning not a fan and we
have to see what's gonna happen we have
to see what's gonna happen but as it
currently stands it's yeah it's a flawed
system there's no doubt about it
yeah so I mean you take you sit there
and you think exactly I mean Christopher
Hart right they're saying it there's
your incentive to even try and
masterwork is not there no one on the
weapons like okay cool you can't master
work exotics so that's not a thing you
can get your catalyst form and that
helps for some but not all weapons have
them so you can't do like just the
master work versus the catalysts like
changing the gun up and then armor you
get a 5% shield
bonus for tier five am I gonna spend
nine course for five percent damage
which I'm probably not gonna feel on a
random role that I can't even choose to
be like hey I want five percent help on
arc damage again okay and then it's like
and then I'm 700 and then two months or
now when this comes out I'm gonna first
thing the 701 okay either I spend the
money to infuse that thing up which I
can but then I don't care about the old
stuff right and then on the other side
like if I break it down somebody said
they had a full set completely master
work broke everything down
they got squat for it you don't even
know we give them back like though the
breakdown was not like nearly equal to
spin all the time that you want it's not
like we break down mod components we get
him back mm-hmm now if I was like if I
could be like hey I'm at like you know
I'm not like $6.99 700 I found my cool
pieces alright I'm gonna start master
working if I knew for a fact I broke
down that piece and be like kale might
wait till I get that new piece of armor
or something like that and if I broke
them all down if I got them all back and
could put that effort back into
something else then you get that benefit
as well because okay I'm not losing the
effort I put in from all these gunsmiths
materials I farm for shards that I had
to buy everything for and the time that
you put in to either go I mean the
tangle short okay so here's your loop on
the tangled chore go open chests and do
public events and these things to get
these currency that you have to buy the
bounties for then you go out back use
the battle use to go do those bounties
to find people in the world to get your
quote to get your course or the other
side is going to be the same with
gunsmith materials go out shoot things
get random things to draw break those
things down and get your guns materials
didn't spend the gunsmiths and two girls
tickets your bounty go to the bounty go
out finish the bounty get your cores
then you're like holy hell I finally
just got a core yeah it's one what I get
this all the while not being able to
play the game you want to play all the
while not being able to do the
objectives and the question really want
to do this again it did this whole
convoluted process and we keep also
negating the fact that it's not just
course they're asking for for infusion
like they still want your shards which
technically you need preserve
technically you need for other things
you know say so it's like
it's just a flawed system and and again
you know child today dude is in the chat
he said they read bungees right now for
me able to make changes on the fly with
hot fixes why not just increase the rate
at which scott scott brownies or master
or master we've consumable drop anything
is better than waiting again i'm not
gonna disrespect them not saying to do
it is but as far as like from a text
standpoint on how it is slow it's just
let's just call it what it is they're
not agile they're slow you know arm but
i think actually they're not slow
because we've seen them come in and do
stuff when they want to do it you know
the difference it's on there they have
the choice to be like hey i want to like
this things break in the game take power
deactivate the gun prism like wasn't it
like they didn't think either had a bug
in it they can take that stuff out and i
know there's a difference between server
and client side things I understand
there's multiple platforms and stuff
like that but whatever their tech is
whatever their builds are those types of
things this is the point where we do
continue to see over the past years of
destiny the three-month sandbox fixes as
opposed to hey this guns a little
unbalanced let's change it next week
yeah or like an anthem like hey this
thing like chests are dropping too many
mass courts in the world it's kind of
wrong damn it's fixed like it's like
literally within hours but again what
this shows me is but what the line of
the sand really is is level throttling
they don't want us to power level I mean
obviously the best of the best are going
to be able to do it the hardcore are
gonna find the way they're gonna do it
well the problem they can't stop the
people they're worried about yeah they
can't stop there's no it doesn't do them
any good to slow down to try and slow
down the top people because they still
gonna find the way do I really like six
different person with Daddy buns you'll
eat this what he's doing nice and he
gonna take the El with all you top-tier
guys do you boxer says all you guys he's
like look we these guys are too smart
they know the ins and outs they'll
figure it out they are looking at the
big pot because let's be honest they got
the metrics on all of this they got them
they're sitting with these numbers on
cores about and i'ma tell you how this
is my theory on how they came to it they
sat there and they said okay
night let's say they thought
theoretically number 80% of our player
base has so many you know weapon
materials right let's give it to the
tabacky right in this way the majority
of the base not the hawk oil I said 20%
is the hawk or our gonna have to do this
to get themselves up as opposed to just
power leveling through because if you
look at the structure of the annual pass
everything is drip-drop per power level
right because when we had black armory
you can't do this vote until you this
level right yeah now you got drifted you
can't do to yourself until you this
level if we power levels right if that
was a road to entry was blocked
I'm not blocked and we were able to get
all this stuff and people with 680
that's what they're doing because this
goes against the drip-feed annual pass
structure that's what they're doing us
that that's this whole thing and that's
why low key I don't like the annual pass
because that's the only in my appearance
got to be the only reason why they're
doing this they want to throttle us they
want to slow us down and they figure
they'll take the loss on the hardcore
they can't stop them but as long as the
masses can't blaze through the content
that just shows me that the system
itself is flawed well look and that's
the problem is like the masses are the
ones you actually want to be able to
play our game and feel like they're
making progress and that is a thing you
hamper with a huge basically just slap
in the face by saying hey I want to work
on my powerful gear on my one character
I've got all I did my powerful gear I
might get a prime in Graham if I keep
doing the same stuff over and over and
this comes back to like we talked about
it last week talked about it on DCP when
I was on there
Holtzman brought it up and just said it
was like we're all getting so tired of
playing the same stuff and that's what
you have to do to jump into leveling you
have to do the same stuff you have to
run your nightclothes you have to run
your daily activities you got to do your
adventures how many times am am I gonna
go run a daily activity just to get like
a piece of powerful gear to level it up
and this is one character am i Titan is
my one at 687 I have not touched my
other two this season you haven't
touched them and I'm getting the point
I'm like you got stuff like the vision
anthem
trying lighting and it's got long road
but it's like they're in a point where
like they will talk about them for a
second what they want it there and there
the point of that space magic in that
game still feels fun broken but fun
absolutely and you're at a point where
it's like I've been in this for so long
and until they tell me what the hell is
coming in September if it's d3 does this
any even matter mm-hmm or if it's not
September if it's like whenever whatever
that next phase of what is coming after
season opulence what that looks like
does it connect what is it gonna be is
it a completely new thing is all this
grind even gonna matter we don't know
and I'm at the point of that's why this
season for me has been slower I didn't
make it to tier three at first and I got
687 because I played a decent month this
week working on stuff but I'm not even
700 yet and that's like and I've played
I feel like a pretty decent amount not
as much but right I've played a decent
amount and I'm not maxed imagine the
person who's like you know say poke bear
if he was gonna be more casual even
though I think he grinded his butt off
but somebody who plays like on the
weekends or I get a couple hours at
night and I go and I do something and
those may be the people that may be ok
with the hey let me run my nightfall
tonight I'll run a couple strikes and
then I'm out and then maybe I'll come
back and play again but maybe they're
not at the point of being burnt out
right but for me it's the point of the
long view they have not added a strike
they have not added a pvp map they added
like those two pieces of combine
completely and I'm not saying those are
easy things to create right pvp maps
probably easier than strikes I know
there's balancing time versus actual
asset creation and that's the point
where it's like an issue of resources
and this is draws back into my final
piece of like whether they're trying to
throttle us whether which feels like
they can't win either way so they're
screwed so honestly quit stopping us
personally you wouldnt try to slow us
down because you're not gonna stop the
big people and let the other people
enjoy it who do get to play casually
because I still think like there's a
small team doing everything they can and
like 80% of that entire studio because
it's all in-house now is working on
whatever's next and that is the piece
where this focus is on where they're
trying to make it good and they have to
you have to absolutely crush it but man
there's some of this stuff that's
leaving a really bad taste
like I know is a long ass ran sorry we
had to talk about I mean that's one
thing I love about this pot doing this
podcast with you is that you know we're
gonna keep it true we love this game but
at the end of the day we got a call a
spade a spade and you know these are
things that need to be rectified and if
you you dissatisfy the bass you know and
the good that's the good thing about
competition right the good thing about a
division being out and a good thing
about an anthem wanna come back we're
gonna get into that you know is that now
they have no choice there's no excuse of
the activision thing they have no choice
if you don't adapt and keep your bass
happy then they're going to go other
places and obviously we love this game
we don't want to see that happen but the
good thing is hopefully the pressure of
these games can get them to kind of
change I will leave it on a positive
note in that the only good thing that I
did see and I know I don't know if we
got a chance to talk about it last time
we did the last word was that a shout
out I believe glad he I saw him put a
post up so it looks like the good ol
community summit is coming back there
for the season of opulence and that made
me smile because I was worried because
we remember - they - launched it was in
a bad space player base you know pretty
much died off corker sir Osiris is
almost like nail in the coffin you know
they said they they sent out the
volunteer squad they want to listen to
the community they brought them down
there you know we seen what happened we
seen we got a forsaken right you know as
far as opulence in the future I'm really
hopeful you know I'm saying that that
gives me hope like it gives me it gives
me positive vibes that at least they're
not that tone that that's where they're
like okay we're not doing that anymore
so we'll see what happens you know we
get the big guys down there hopefully
they send the pvp community as well
there's the you just want them to listen
man because we make this game you know
I'm saying we make this game and I don't
want to see anything bad happens
especially when they're on their own now
so that's all I got on it what you think
about the whole community summit think
four we move on I mean the more yeah the
more the merrier in there I mean last
time we had different things of I mean I
don't know what the specific piece of
the change was but I know other
was one of those they're like hey how
about this and the whole like crowd that
was there was like nope
so I mean yes if they're open to saying
things like that and people come back
and be like I'm sorry but the core suck
like they need to be open years at some
point to finally be like okay all these
people from all these different spaces
we're tired of this crap
yeah why haven't defenders been updated
well I have like there's there's so many
things from like D ones that were there
and it's like it's still not all in this
game all there and I don't know if it's
like hey do we have enough resources
okay we got this investment Nettie's we
broke off on our own we're working
forward to be like hey d2 has this like
weird stuff going on we don't know
they're our analysts yeah the catalysts
which have been you know we're faction
rallies where is the catalyst from the
faction rallies where are the catalysts
where are catalysts for any piece of
armour ever mm-hmm all of that stuff
it's like it's not there so there are
many things that have been discussed
thought about previously in theory and
so much I feel has not panned out yeah
that I that again it's that concept of
like they have to be working on other
stuff because that studio is large like
they're one of the biggest technically
Indies kind of per se jokingly like
there what are the biggest Studios like
completely on their own
they're huge and there's a whole bunch
of people and I'm not saying any of this
stuff is easy to create shout out to
every one of the developers there I know
they're working their butt off these are
higher level decisions that some people
like hey I'm working on making this art
SS for this piece of armour cool you are
killing it art always you know there's
certain pieces always doing their job
but in turn like some of the high-level
decisions for the player experience that
piece of feedback like I know it's like
you know they they set expectations at
least when this 12 was coming out like
Dylan was out there day before saying
hey this stuff isn't going away we'll be
talking about it more I mean as soon as
that was said I was just I was literally
on Twitch that night and I was just like
in my min you talking to my stream for
like it was probably 15 minutes just
ranting and I would literally went
throws like okay so I know it's 17 for
weapons it's gonna be so armored and be
like it's one it's three it's five so
it's nine for people for a piece and 96
I was like and that just like I went off
in my stream and that comes just back to
this whole piece of
experience of you have division that has
sets that start early on you get a feel
you get those editions of things coming
in and some of that stuff builds and
there are random roles I understand that
piece but it's like little first line of
this whole thing the goal of the
infusion system has created an impactful
feeling of progression when you increase
the power of an item you're using okay
an impact is one thing but I'm like okay
so if you impact and then master work
like we get enough random roles Trent
like I finally got and I got an amazing
role I got Ursa Furioso which has it
something downs for uses but it has
finally got my combo of machine gun
scavenger and machine gun targeting
first time on a pair of gauntlets from
four in the class and I'm like holy crap
like I finally got one it's sitting on
an exotic which is fine but I'm like
that took me that long to get it's not
done yeah question um maybe this is my
inexperience with the black army can you
tell me why she's not selling the pulse
rifle France for three weeks because I'm
late
broadly I am so livid with with ADA's
lack of updating because here's that
they remember there was no power surge
bounty for Cognito little Okonedo came
to pc he had to grind all the way from
300 up to whatever was the 600 right huh
and I get there I can't do none of her
bounties because I gotta get Izanami out
I did Izanami out now the new contents
out I'm like okay cool I'll still do
black armory
I was excited when I can really
experience black army the way I want to
because now I'm off power level go to
her here she come with the auto rifle
the bow and whatever the whack other
third weapon a sword and oh my god been
like the same three two and A three have
been the same for each it's not updated
inventory can I get a shot at the black
what is it the black furnace what is it
the brass they've literally flipped out
they've had the Auto rifle the sword and
it's between like sitar gaze and the bow
like back and forth for multiple weeks
like haven't seen hammerhead in three
weeks haven't seen blast furnace in
three weeks like what the hell yeah
it's driving me crazy so that's what I
knew
I was like well maybe is because I
didn't do any before and as I said I
keep forgetting to ask you and I was
like we have discussions and I'm glad it
came up now because I thought I was
losing my mind I'm like this vendor does
not change on reset for three weeks
likes literally for season of the forge
it was literally flip-flopping between
mostly like you'd have like all like
every other week you'd probably see most
of them like if not in within three but
I was like usually was a flip between
like back and forth between kind of the
sets of three they were also is there
and now it's been like it's like two
slots are broken on the rotation I'm
like we'll fix it yeah so yeah I mean
meteor cores like I've lost my mind on
it a couple of times at this point but
it's one of those that it is a it takes
away from your ability to really dive
deep into an in-game because one what's
the point as we know the power levels
gonna go up again to a custom fusion
cores they get there in three it the
benefit heart like the benefit of a set
love master working armor hardly even
matters that's the question I have in so
minimum I want like they said all the
you know they they're always so you know
paradox of choice or basically you know
too much data to make like a decision
I'm like take the data and figure out I
want to know how many people have
mastered a piece of armor or how many
people have mastered armors that they
have chosen to spend cores on how many
cores have been spent on armor it's got
to be small yeah I agree
so I know we beat that topic to death
sorry guys but it had to be done
artists mal for a tional II sometimes
they come out eloquently sometimes they
don't we'll see ya and shout out to dom
barnes and my dad he's like doesn't even
seem like pvp was considered the season
started you you literally have a recluse
which I hear is actually pretty solid by
the way only but that's it I mean you
got ddossing and comp pvp CD player base
is brutally rough on comp but like no
Maps no modes no not even a mode like
I mean crucible abs
this unused resource they haven't
brought that thing up in how long since
for was it for sake of nothing launched
yeah yeah they did like a three test and
then they haven't touched it again are
you guys not trying anything I think if
you are share the knowledge with us get
some hype going forward and the king of
introducing new figs observes and then
completely backing away from it and you
never hear from if you kid you like wait
a minute this fart was cool yeah listen
I know how things go when you're in
transition the only pass I'm giving them
is after the season of opulence which is
the last of the bungee I mean the
Activision quote-unquote influenced or
not influenced depending on who you talk
to you know contract content that once
that's ended we're gonna learn a lot
come September or whenever that next DLC
decides to pop its head or maybe not pop
its head you know in d3 we'll see I'm
slowly so that's the big one they did
show the stats for the people who picked
and we we already talked about our
guests on this one seventy five percent
account level went gambit because if you
have one character you're likely to do
that character level you went 70 and 30
so usually that second character might
look be looking at Vanguard but yeah
two out of three absolutely and it's not
a shocker so I don't know the compelling
piece of you're not gonna get a full
lobe lore book if you don't go Vanguard
so second character might be okay but
generally gambits the popular and it's
not a big surprise we already they do
have a hotfix coming for a couple things
we don't need to go all fully in depth
on that one they still have their known
issues if you have any questions about
those jump in they're all right there
read them and then outside of that
couple movies of the week and we kind of
wrap up with they have the next bounty
for PC players because they've done Xbox
they've done ps4 PC will be April 3rd 12
o'clock somebody's saying like why are
all the bounties always in the middle of
the day like some people be like could
you don't weekend and even anything I
know like I know somebody's got to come
in and be off hours but it's like if
you're gonna make a little move the
day's around a little bit not everybody
gets the play during the day Oh
but you got one more quick topic we're
going to touch under hand from one of
the pieces tas thg no shadow mounts we
got numbers coming out for sales with
regards and it's honestly one of those
things is that everybody's kind of
surprised it made a hundred million
dollars in digital revenue so and
basically I would say about trying to
remember how much exactly but honestly
it was like very a minimal amount from
like microtransactions maybe like three
or four million most of it was from
sales and this is just pure digital so
it doesn't include what am I trying to
think of does include physical sales
like actual off the box like put it in
put the disk in type things so that
one's not included so that's definitely
one of those things to consider but it's
like 100 billion is not a small number
yeah this was this was a pleasant
surprise
um we all know you know the stumbles you
know we've talked about it at nauseam
you know where as far as just getting
out the gate wrong and we we all agree
the whole gameplay is there the being
Iron Man the game and specialized
classes the core aspect is there but
there definitely were a lot of issues
from a technical aspect as well as the
gameplay loop and the loot drops and so
on and so forth
so you know we're not gonna get it to
that but at the end of the day you know
one of the biggest fears especially as a
Bioware fan was that as bad as this game
quote-unquote supposedly launched right
the fear is hey this game is not gonna
do well it's not gonna sell well the
reviews were very low very bad and you
know I'm not trying to say that was
pollen or people had legitimate concerns
and gripes now we hear this and to see
that them on the top of NPD February
2019 and remember people I understand a
lot um with this particular one is even
more so impressive to me because PC
digital sales were not included in this
and I I don't want to undercut like the
whole you know it was a big thing on PC
we know damn well it runs well on PC as
opposed to console
I'll say how about for that but um yeah
this is good to see because at the end
of the day
you know we do we mate may as a long
time to wait for the next con to be
contacting with the cataclysms but Italy
this gives Bioware confidence to EA and
this like despite everything we're still
here we're still selling well the big
boys up top feel good when they see
these type of numbers that Daddy that
reinforces support in hopefully it can
maintain hopefully I just you know
hopefully it's not too big a drop off
the next couple of months and they kind
of maintain you know and this is good to
me overall it's good for the hope of the
the longevity of the franchise because
you want them to stick around you won't
buy a way to stick around you want this
game to stick around and um I was
actually happy about this so kudos to
this keep it up apparently the
second-best
Bioware launch ever known after its
Effect 3 and we all know how big you
know you Bioware guys or how big Mass
Effect 3 was for that for that whole you
know devil team so um yeah this is good
stuff this is good stuff man beat out
jump for us Kingdom Hearts a lot of
competition you know and to see them do
that so let's see what happens you know
but what do you think about it I mean
it's a good thing they obviously said
like for digital it was three and a half
billion rows of microtransactions which
is fairly small Tassie's or the article
was basically saying like apex legends
for example made like 93 million in
micro transactions and you know fairly
similar times so it's like yeah it did
out earn in the beginning with the
initial sales but those micro
transactions may be a piece of like how
much like how much how many people have
stuck around it wasn't much of one
second from my understanding according
to a map piscatella
we had him on our pocket I believe don't
quote me I gotta ask him this but I
believe that the ei origin and access
stuff is not counted in this regard so
if you're wondering yeah actually if
that's the case that's even more
impressive because I know a huge amount
of people that said hey I'm just gonna
do it you know I did it I got premier
origin you know I'm like I'm gonna get
that and for that for those people to
not be counting we know that's a huge
percentage we
PC digital sales also not counted and
for it to still win NPD pretty
impressive yeah so I mean it's it's got
its feet out there and just saying hey
it's like I tried to walk I stumbled
hardcore I face-planted like it is they
are trying to pick it back up and yes
that's the other piece is they have a
new like major changes coming
you got cosmetic chest coming you've got
legendary missions that are gonna start
coming through so you play back through
they kind of streamlined the mission so
you're not seeing as many cutscenes
because you've seen them before
but it's a chance to gets higher level
pieces I know people have been jumping
back in they've been changed in the loot
drops from you know like Grand Master
twos like two master works in the end
grand master three is like three I've
been trying to ball that stuff up and
they've been trying but again there's
also pieces where it is still fairly
broken on their baseline like either
math or damaged mechanics which is why
that stat page that people would love to
see it's probably not there for a reason
because it is kind of at a broken point
so me if I jump up a fly around throw
grenades out and that's like I'm
shooting stuff and like you know
something when I got my first master
work it's like change kind of the way I
played that stuff is cool it's a tile
and it's just to a point of like this is
an OK game that hopefully for some if
they take the break they might burn out
on other places things like that and
then it's like if Cataclysm is cool
enough it might be enough to bring some
people are on to be like ok they've had
a couple months hopefully they've
settled some things out and if that is a
point of bringing people back to say is
this something cool does it give it some
depth is this more in-game is does it
change things up enough and if it does
they got a decent shot because enough
people own it though they're not gonna
let go return it now there's been a few
other things and stuff aside but
generally they it was like I've still
got the admiration for them for trying
but it's also like I think at some point
somebody's like you have to put this out
there whatever it is and I was like I
was like and there's no way they didn't
know all the stuff that was there like I
know you get a millions of people's
hands and there are things as you said
like there was a thing in Division 2
because they're like don't use the drone
because then it crash other people's
games like that's a pretty big one that
you're like how much you guys play test
this like yeah and those are the
things you have to ask even more on
anthem to be like how much you guys play
test this because it seems like squat so
those are some of the pieces of just
like things being rushed and hurried
live as a service their speed of like
having 200 fixes already is a good thing
but you had to fix 200 things as a bad
thing mm-hmm
absolutely so like it's the fact that
they're able to make and adapt changes
quickly they're also kind of being a bit
stubborn when it comes to loot because
the bug times when the loot drops like
crazy town and people love it because
again you're at random roles and then
they keep taking it away everybody's
like why why are you doing that so
there's a lot of options out there like
destiny has like some cool things like a
game that Prime is cool but then you
have a set of armor that works in
literally one bubble on your director
not even normal get it literally says
gambit in the word gambit and then it
only works in game at primum how can you
not carry that stuff over to game but
maybe not even all the perks cuz but
like the collector making the motes less
longer the invader set having an over
shield like some of those things could
still carry over you might not be able
to have like bonuses on the envoys or
like the the way the trip the third
envoy works for you're like that's your
Slayer phase that might be a little
different but some of the perks could
work like so there's at least a little
more use I mean it's like hey we did
sets it's like you you struck out
hardcore when you try to do sets like
they in theory some of the perks are
cool it gives you different roles stuff
like that you need a lot more of them
and you need to be having some more
general bonuses to them as well it's
like anthem comes out face-plants
they're working on fixing it and they
are working their absolute butts off and
division comes out here's a lot of
content divisions like hey guys you can
work on this we've been like doing a
research we we kind of put all this
stuff in there and blow this for a while
so you got 50 hours of content you got
the black test that comes in like and
that's a game for me it's like as I'm
gonna work on SEC euro first but when
that first playthrough is done the
visions like divisions my next piece and
that's gonna be something that sounds
like for me not worrying as much about
the dark zone I know I harp on it but I
don't need to turn around and they learn
that lesson so that's a piece on
division I can solo the whole damn game
is over the black tusk like work on
these legendary missions and if I have
people and I can join them too but as
like that's
what we've all been saying is they all
need to pay attention to learn but I
honestly worry about bungee versus the
other two because they cannot act fast
enough
yeah they got to get on it man cuz the
other two have shown that they are way
more faster so again good thing the good
thing about this is this brings
competition back into the fold these
guys can reinvest these guys can really
get back into it and cars are driving ok
cool but home but outside of that like
no they can really really double down
and really try to fix him and salvage
and like I said if they're good if
anthems good if divisions good forces
destinies hand that's what I want
competition is a beautiful thing bro
yeah so I mean that pretty much wraps up
this week I'd say you mean division
Nick's like positive thoughts on
division most people are enjoying it I
mean reviews I've seen you know eights
nines I mean no game of that size is
gonna be perfect but right of what is
out there people are enjoying most of it
like the gameplay has a vast amount of
crap to do so really having a good time
with it I didn't think I would I didn't
think I would enjoy it as much as I have
it's really been fun and then you got
you know Toit's will just watch and see
what destiny decides to think if the
community summit if they get a good mix
of people like hopefully representing
everyone from like your hardcore first
day you know world's first people to
hopefully them being aware enough for
reddit's and Twitter's and things like
that to be like hey the other side the
casuals like how do you balance you
don't over casual is it but it's like
you're not making any better choices
just by trying to slow everybody down
cuz the top people are still gonna do it
so and then to wrap everything up anthem
as well it's like I still want to jump
back I've like I haven't played that in
a little while because I've just been
kind of waiting for things to kind of
settle so I know it's one though it's
like when I jump on my interceptor my
brother was like I haven't even actually
touched it since the patch he said the
Interceptor like feels damn good now
like the melee was buffed as the
difficulty went up so now the
Interceptor is like feeling stronger
side if I wouldn't jump back on my space
ninja I know now there's a good man I
would look see like I say when they add
new stuff patch it up
do what they got to do and give
community what they want yeah man the
game feels good look great play you know
like I say great I would love to get
back in there again yeah and I do want
one more announcements all you guys out
there I'm also gonna like record this
before the podcast as well and kind of
stick it on the front of the video
version for me so if you want to put it
in the notes on your site as well
podcast I know you guys catch it on
Twitch and you guys see it on the
YouTube channel it is an audio only form
now and I want to shout out anchored on
FM thank you Mark from Guardian radio it
was really really really easy process me
I hadn't even done much audio and I know
you've done it more but I just tried to
be like alright so here's the audio it
took care of like everything so this
podcast is on Spotify gone I I tunes
it's on Google podcasts there's like
four other platforms it's on podcasts
only it's on like eight different
podcast platforms right now so if you
guys are looking for it this one will be
going up today or tomorrow so the audio
will be there and that will be a thing
going forward so I've got from number 50
going forward I didn't go that far so
audio is live and will be there so
that's the way if you guys to take the
podcast with you as opposed to be like
YouTube is killing me for a three hour
podcast exact exact big request finally
got done like I said he got that bad
audio going we've moving up in the world
a little bit drying it out the slow low
- it's out - these guys Josh for coming
really great guest man I would do these
outros real quick after we made the big
announcement yeah so I mean shout outs
to the guests thank them for coming in
of course like it's nice to have other
opinions for sure before I start like
ranting about cores in between us at the
rock so good to have different people in
here especially when things like
division like it's a huge looter shooter
launches let's get people who've
definitely been in there and you know no
life it up to 450 or 420 Oh
Malta pacat refers to a sort work right
there so put new work and and then Josh
jumping in from the coffee shop Thank
You surfer for making the step hey it's
like world breeze that he's like I'm
getting on there I'm gonna make it work
one way the other so relatively thank
you
thank you for getting in here dropping
some blower bombs on us and having an
awesome time but for me it's easy it's
he bounces everywhere so if you guys are
listening watching you can find me on
YouTube on twitch on Twitter it's EB Ont
is Ibanez and you know if you find a
cheetah you're in the right place so you
know where to find me and I've been
trying to stream a lot more I'm trying
to figure out my damn streaming upload I
gotta go harass my cable company again
so all of those pieces aside that's
where you guys are gonna find me and I'm
gonna be streaming a lot of Secura so
it's that's gonna be a learning
experience live so you guys can watch me
struggle hardcore hopefully in the
beginning and then if I can get my act
together and be skilled
I might actually see about some videos
and boss guides and stuff like that so I
will see if I can feel like I'm good
enough to get a guide out there because
if I'm sucking it up and I'm not gonna
tell you guys how to do it at Lord cog
mill you know check us out
IOP iron Lords podcast Sunday special
time actually it's gonna be 2:00 p.m.
Eastern because we want to adhere to our
special guest from New Zealand it is the
one and only bela rise of real games
media and she's actually one of the
first people i really supported on a
podcast from the back of the day she's a
forum a game developer herself hardcore
gamer haven't had her on in a long time
we're gonna talk a lot about some stadia
an interesting topic like no we're gonna
break down today but yeah definitely an
interesting one
buckle up man we're gonna have a lot to
say about that so again it's gonna be a
2 p.m. Eastern on Sunday and on only on
what podcast YouTube channel and again
please like I've got a shout to slow-mo
again it shout out to Josh reading again
please check out Lords of gaming dotnet
if you can man it's our website you got
guys like Josh we got some really cool
talented guys out there and putting out
articles and if you want good destiny
article especially the lore he's got a
killer one right now about the
invitation of 9 he's really doing a good
job man so salute to those guys in the
writing team and we're just doing it you
know grassroots man for the people for
the you know gamers talking about games
yeah check us out my Iowa podcast you
already know and of course the last word
every Friday 9:00 a.m. Eastern Oh full
disclosure I am NOT going to be a rare
next week because um the Lord's are
gonna be impacts East so we'll check
them out guys follow them follow the
YouTube page iron Lords podcast they
will probably be getting some videos up
as well maybe getting to see if they can
get some nice exclusivity on anything a
certain gear box gave me a lot of people
like maybe seeing firsthand so we don't
need another way to show Jesus I know
ludis we gonna have to have another
topic as the show evolves we'll see but
maybe like everybody's like my god lion
like last word is four freaking hours
yeah man so we already know what the
rumors are they've been hinting at it
heavily we're gonna be out there for
four days so I'm probably next week
we'll catch back the week after I'll
link up with my man II and we'll do it
again but yeah when you get a chance
please again stay tuned buckle up for
PAX East supposed to be a lot being
shown and we can't wait to get our hands
on and cover it awesome well thank you
guys chats been awesome both sides on
ILP and right here on Twitch on mind you
guys have been awesome today so thank
you guys great commentary thank you guys
for hanging out check out the audio
versions in case you missed some of them
because it is out there as well and that
is the last word please have a good one